september 9th fiscal committee
uh to order
and uh
before i start um
many of you in the audience today
had a wonderful trip to the top of mount
washington
and i understand that some of you have
never been there before
so i'm glad that you had the opportunity
to see one of our
greatest icons in in the state
executive councilor kenny for for
setting that up for you and
so anyhow i just i just thought that was
an interesting
day for everyone
so first on the agenda
are acceptance of the
minutes for
uh july 22nd
and
oh i guess we need to do july 22nd
so
okay we have a motion from senator
rosenwald
second
from senator daniels
are there any questions comments
yes
chairwoman i'll be abstaining from this
vote since i was not present okay no
problem
all right well the clerk
do we need to call the role
yeah let's just do a show of hands all
right all in favor
opposed
okay i have two
abstentions uh one from representative
earth
oh you weren't here
oh
okay
we have three extensions and senator uh
perkins kawawa is that how it's
pronounced
uh quoca perkins quoca quoca okay oh the
cage the kw is the q
as in uh okay like in kuwait
okay i can get that
all right
um
the second uh set of minutes that we
have to approve
is the um
august 10th
um
fiscal committee meeting
and uh could i have a motion
senator gray
thank you do i have a second
second by senator daniels
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
oh okay sorry
yes
thank you very much appreciate that
okay
um
old business uh to the best of my
knowledge there is
22-2023 off the table
is that correct
all right
uh the following items are removed from
the consent calendar
fis-275
fis-277
fis-278
fis-291
fis-315
fis-317
fis-300
fis-302
fis-304
fis-305
fis-313
and
fis-316
are there any other items to come off
yes
this is probably an issue with my notes
but my notes suggested uh 312.
we might want to pull that off of
consent but i'll defer to your notes
because i'd have to go back and look at
no i had that as okay but if you'd like
to take it off we certainly can if you
don't mind just taking it off and we can
just deal with it rapidly if that's
not an issue i just i'm just not ready
to speak to it in a moment
okay
uh could i have a motion to accept all
of the other items on the consent
calendar
senator bradley moves second by senator
gray
representative edwards
yes
henrik votes yes representative irf yes
represent leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator bradley yes
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator perkins
coca yes
representative umberger
yes
random tear the vote is 10-0
vote being 10 to zero
those items on the consent calendar
have passed
i would like to
complement natural and cultural
resources
for the
tremendous job that they did
dealing with
the parks
and
that is an example
for everyone to look at and
hopefully imitate
so i i definitely want to thank the
people at natural and cultural resources
okay
we now turn to
tab sorry tab four i can't read
okay
no i don't want to table it
okay um we will come back to that when
commissioner jasper or
someone
okay just
just turn on the mic if you would
uh commissioner jasper apologizes for
not being here
i'm representing the department of
agriculture
and do you have a name sorry yes josh
marshall director of the division of
agricultural development
i do have one question
and um
that is that your proposal
i was told that the position is fully
funded
i i was told that the position is funded
well it's it's looking to be funded
through this um
fis that's here
the i believe that the the position was
a full-time
position when it came to the department
of agriculture and that uh the this is
the the
okay
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
oh i need a motion
okay
uh senator bradley moves uh senator
fis-275 representative edwards yes the
275. eric votes yes representative irf
yes representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator bradley yes senator
gray yes senator rosenwald
yes senator perkins quoca yes
representative umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is 10-0 vote being
ten to zero fis
22 275 passes
277.
which is uh department of health and
human services
for money for birthing centers
good morning nathan white with the
department of health and human services
good morning
um
are there
uh
questions yes uh
representative edwards uh thank you man
i'm sure um
so on on 277 uh i have just a specific
question out of curiosity and just a
general observation one
the the thing that comes closest to a
question is
um this is this is funding to help with
hospital birthing services a valuable
but
to the more general point
is
this
write-up has a description of the
services it's a it's a qualitative
description of what we're doing but
there's nothing quantifiable in here i i
don't
reading this i don't have a sense
of of what this 2.4 million dollars will
deliver
and you know what the value add is and
you know just just the things that we
need to do to do our due diligence for
the taxpayers to know that we're
investing our money as opposed to just
rubber stamping a
narrative jordan
i i can certainly speak to that so um
and and i'm going to speak to 277 and
278 at the same time and and because
they're very similar
um so house bill 1661 uh appropriated
funding in in 227
you'll see 2.4 million for rate
increases for birthing services and then
the personal care attendant roughly 700
was also appropriated in general funds
for through hb 1661
and so we were appropriated those funds
through that bill
and then you'll see reference in here we
had a question come through about why
why are we referencing general funds and
we why did we submit a memo to the
department administrative services so we
submitted a memo to accept those funds
into our budget and what you see here is
you see the federal matching funds the
50 50 federal matching funds to
effectuate uh the directive of the
legislature through hp in 60 61.
so what what you're seeing here this is
the mechanics of us accepting the
follow-ups
all right i i i'm going to move on
because i i had no intent to oppose this
but i i'm not sure that you've heard
what i've said so maybe i've said it
poorly
you can describe something qualitatively
and you can describe something
quantitatively and it's the quantitative
that helps me get my head around exactly
what the program
scope
value
benefits are and that's not in this
document and since you brought up 278
it's the same observation i i i'm i'm
good i'm good for a good story i just
want enough math to know what we're
doing um and and what the benefit is
that's all and i'm not going to hold
this up i i just want to emphasize that
so that in future write-ups we we see
a a quantitative description of the
benefit for the money that we're going
to invest that's all
thank you madam chair
okay
okay so
i was going to move to pass but i'm
going to okay
senator rosenwald thank you i have a
question sometimes
in the legislation we include a sentence
that says
the department may accept
federal matching funds
without having to go to fiscal
did we not do that in this piece of
legislation and that's why we have to
accept the federal funds yes that is
correct senator rosenwald that language
was not included in hb 1661 which is why
are there further
questions of senator bradley uh thank
you very much madam chair i would just
note for the record that that was my
bill that was um put on to
house bill 1661 it was a request of the
department written by the department so
um just want to make the sure the record
i was not in my role at the time but i
will take full i will take the fall for
that
okay
move to approve all right
okay a motion from senator gray to
approve
and seconded by senator bradley
if i asked 277 representative edwards uh
yes to 277. hammering votes yes very
same earth yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator bradley yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins cuoco yes
representative umberger yes
madam share the vote is 10-0
thank you the vote being 10 to 0 fis 22
277 passes
we now turn to fis
22 278
uh
i i would move to approve i i think we
just discussed it okay
i have a question man okay
uh
representative leitchman
thanks madam chair um
in some of the material you provided the
committee just before the meeting i
guess yesterday there was a chart now
this is probably a good place to bring
it up or not but
in table eight of the information you
provided it talked about clients served
by community mental health centers
and i was just curious
in 2012 but this is this on table eight
it shows a
remarkable decline between
2012 and 2020. could you tell me why
there's been a decline
sure i'm gonna have katya fox our uh
director for division of behavioral
health come up
is
representative leishman are you sure
you're on 278 yeah it was in a package
of um responses 278 there were a number
of charts he provided to what's uh
yesterday i believe in response to
okay
so good morning madam chair um for
clarification this is part of the
dashboard so it's part um when he
references tab eight
it's the it's the the dashboard the
operating statistics but i'd be happy to
respond to that question now
okay
yep uh representing unleashing this one
something
yeah it was just in that whole package
that we got so i
figured it's a good chance probably to
ask the question okay well can we hold
off oh sure all right
because that
okay uh
represent edwards has moved
oh the clerk please call the rule okay
first 278 representative edwards yes to
278 votes yes representative irf yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator bradley yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins cloaca yes
representative umbrerver yes madam chair
the vote is 10 to nothing
the vote being 10 to nothing
fis-278
passes
okay the next one that we're taking off
is
uh still
fis290
okay
this one we loved about the iv service
that you're providing
i think it was supposed to read title
we we did have a good laugh about that
so we're
really looking forward to that
so uh
are there questions that
represent earth
or i'm sorry that's her that's all right
i still know who i am uh
so so
madam chair thank you uh in my comments
to 291 this is basically a three pack of
uh of requests that we received where um
it's for addition this one's for
additional uh workload and pay for
marital masters and and
there's no way i would want to oppose
that we need to do that but i'm i'm just
missing
the numeric
story behind this to understand
you know the richness the vibrancy the
status of this program
these are just these are just
sterile stale words
and i i want numbers so
so i i
am prepared to move to approve
with just the request that in the future
we we we tell the other side of the
story
quantitative as well as qualitative
thank you
okay
do i have a second or are there any
other questions
at bias 291 yes
fis-291 representative edwards uh yes to
emrick votes yes representative earth
yes representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator bradley yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins yes
representative umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is ten to zero the
vote being ten to zero fis
passes
we now turn to fis 22
317 from the governor's office of
good morning good morning good morning
taylor caswell executive director gopher
chase hageman deputy director of gopher
great and glad to have you here
um
are there uh questions that folks have
thank you madam chair
i wonder if you could provide an
overview of where
should i speak louder no i got you i got
you
yeah um where this program stands it's
been going on for
well basically since the through the
pandemic and more specifically once you
get through that
what happens when all these and there's
there's this one there's several others
i believe in this same uh today and i'll
just address them all here
what happens when all these rental
assistance programs end at some point in
the future yeah so this uh this program
emanates going going back as you pointed
out i believe the december of 2021 was
the first round of the we call the
emergency rental assistance program
it's been operational in new hampshire
from
roughly a couple months after that and
then a second tranche of funds that came
um later in 2021 i don't know if i had
my march 21 march 2020. anyway um so at
this point we have spent probably a
little over 200 million dollars
of those funds from the federal
government under this program through
new hampshire housing
they are the
the administrator of this program
i don't have the exact numbers in terms
of the number of families that have been
assisted but it is a substantial amount
over the course of the program what
you're looking at here in this item is
22 317
relates to the first trunk of the funds
that we've received the state of new
hampshire received under that program
which we refer to as era one those funds
are due to expire at the end of
september
and so what we're asking for here is to
take the remaining amount that we have
allocated to er a1
and get those over to new hampshire
housing so that they can uh can spend
down those dollars prior to the end of
right i understood that thank you um but
there's another one in here if i think
another 10 million dollars or 20 million
dollars if not mistaken i just maybe
capture them all here at one time but
more particularly my real question is
related to all of these
is what happens when these programs end
so at this point it's hard for us to
have any sort of idea exactly when this
is going to end because we do have an
expectation that at some point we're
told over the next few weeks there will
be another tranche of funding
under the era 2 program which is a later
item
that will keep the program uh keep the
program running
so uh we're hopeful that we're going to
be able to drag this to the point where
we are able to plan for some level of
transition for people that are in the
program
now but at this point it's hard for us
to say exactly when that is going to be
may if i'll just please i wasn't asking
for the end point i get that you don't
know when it is i hope it's not never
i'm just wondering have you so have you
started thinking about the fact that it
might end and these people have been
used to this over what has been two
maybe three maybe four years maybe more
i don't know but if you get some some
thought to what's going to happen to
these folks when
if
it does end
well it is going to end at some point
that that is a fact i think what we're
working with now with new hampshire
housing and with the cap agencies is a
series of other programs that go with
this rental and utility assistance that
go to things like
transitional services support services
uh and funding to assist people to
be able to make themselves get
themselves into a more permanent housing
solution this program was in its
you know in its initial design um really
designed to be able to help people get
through
a lack of a job or the downturn the
economic downturn and not able to pay
their rent or their utility costs and so
we've you know seen great success in
that program but as it does end we're
going to have to lean pretty heavily on
the services that are being provided now
and expand those and extend those
um in order to support those people that
are not able to transition to a more
so any further questions
senator daniels thank you
following up on that statement
the documentation says in the event the
federal funds are no longer available
general funds will not be requested to
support the program but it sounds like
what you just said
that you would be asking for general
funds
later to support those
the federal funds that aren't there
anymore no i should i should i should
clarify that um
and really kind of important maybe to
another item later on is that under era
which is the second tranche of funding
obviously that program allows us to
spend until 2025
and so you'll see a later item here that
takes a lot of the services and the
programs that i described a moment ago
transitions those over to era 2 and
enables us to continue to spend
under that program until at least you
know at the longest we could go with
that would be 2025.
so
effectively what we're asking here
between these items is to
fully utilize the era funding for the
rental assistance and utility systems
and then to in addition to continuing
that program under era 2
shift the the cost of those support
services to era 2 because we have a
longer horizon to spend those in order
to avoid
and to make sure that we're using
federal funds for those
for those programs follow up follow up
go ahead um
have has the department been monitoring
uh this program i mean this started back
in in the covered
in the heart of covert uh with two
percent unemployment
right now one would expect that maybe
the numbers would have gone down because
people are employed and now have uh jobs
that they didn't have back then and so
maybe they don't need as much
assistance with rental
as a department following that
monitoring that enough so that you can
give us some sort of a historical
graphing of what's happening yeah the
the the level of monitoring that goes on
with this program is pretty substantial
and in fact most of it is right on the
website with the numbers and where it's
being used and how much is being used
and number of families that are being
served and so on i think the thing to
remember too is that while we are
definitely seeing the reduction
in the unemployment rate we still have
seeing very very low vacancy rates
across the state
and a lot of those particularly rental
unit rent
costs are not seeing the same decrease
as the unemployment rate
so it does remain a challenge for a lot
of people
yeah i'm sure
are there further yes uh represent
leishman
thanks madam chair
so i have two questions one is a
follow-up to representative earth's
questions do you have a rough idea how
many people are being served you said
you didn't have a number but you must
have a rough idea i'm going to ask chase
hi chase eggman deputy director at
gopher um i i made a note because i
assume this question would come uh to
date we've provided over um 200 million
dollars in assistance
to over 21 000 households
and a follow-up if i could but i'm sure
yes you may
thanks um
i don't believe we've seen any of the
contractual language that you've had
with the federal government for
receiving these funds but there's no
like claw back language in there that
the federal government will be looking
for any sort of reimbursement from these
federal funds
uh that's a good question representative
there are reallocations within these
programs that the federal government has
already been engaging and in fact the 12
million dollars from this item is 12
million dollars being reallocated from
other jurisdictions to new hampshire to
support its program
thanks thanks madam chair okay uh
representative edwards
thank you madam chair uh this is this is
a general concern i think you and i
talked about this once in a previous
fiscal committee meeting and and i'm i'm
just concerned with our vacancy rate of
rentals as low as they are as we
continue to pump more money into chasing
fewer and fewer facilities
that we are
likely to be contributing to the
inflationary
nature of the rental increases
and we're exacerbating a problem for
those who are chasing
property that aren't receiving the
benefit of government funds
and last time i mentioned it i i i think
it was the first time you and i had ever
talked about it i'm just curious in the
months since then
have you given any thought to that
dilemma
uh and whether or not we have a valid
cause to worry that we're part of the
problem
well i'm certainly familiar with that
with that concern representative and i
think that you know we are not the only
state
that is spending resources federal
government resources under this program
i think the scope and the scale
of the rental
shortage and the costs in new hampshire
predated in a lot of cases the situation
that we're experiencing right now
as you are aware we've also
requested and approved and are running a
program called invest nh which is a
hundred million dollars a federal
program to assist getting more of these
rental units online
i think exacerbating the situation
pretty significantly
is the increase in mortgage rates
as you see it more difficult to become
for
individuals and families to purchase a
home
it continues to put downward pressure on
our rental units that are available so
people are staying in rental units that
normally in sort of a healthy housing
market you would see this churn of
people moving from you know maybe a one
bedroom to a three bedroom and then to a
house
that the leap to the house has become a
bigger leap than it was just a few
months ago and so it's
there's a number of factors that are
going into the cost of the rental
markets right now in new hampshire this
you know one could certainly argue is
part of it but it is a
problem on a national scale
certainly on a regional scale and we're
trying to alleviate that with some of
the other programs that we have running
are there further questions
i do have one
and you probably
won't be able to answer it but
if someone is qualifying under this
program
will they also be receiving la heap
money
do you have
i think we have
we might be able to answer that question
oh good thank you it's a question that's
come before representative the way the
systems are designed is the two are not
competing sources of assistance so
there's a tracking mechanism to make
sure those who are receiving liheap are
not duplicatively receiving uh era
utility assistance so
to the extent that lie heap is
unavailable to a household then the era
assistant steps in
okay so
that was my concern that we were
double dipping if that's the right term
okay thank you very much
all right are there further questions
uh senator rosenwald moves fi s
317 seconded by
senator bradley
roll call fs317
representative edwards yes to 317.
emeric votes yes ruby same irf yes
represent leishman yes senator daniels
yes senator bradley yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins quoca yes representative
umberger yes man i'm sure the vote is
ten to zero the vote being ten to zero
fis 317
passes
we now move to
tab 7
fis
22 300.
this is also from
gopher
okay
are there let me just go to my page here
300.
sorry for the work being done
downstairs i feel like someone's going
to pop through a hole right here any
second
well a real
that is really sorry sorry i've been
waiting for two years to use that yeah
well it's uh i'll tell you what it's not
a bad thing
we could jump into caddyshack anytime
yeah are you sure this is is this are
you sure this is the right career for
you
[Laughter]
yet to be determined
oh yet to be determined okay fine
uh
all right
tab seven
well i'm trying to find this um
yeah in my book are there any other
questions
okay
um
this is uh authorization for
youth and adult homeless shelters is
that correct
if i
yeah youth and young adult yes youth and
young adult
[Music]
is this in addition to
the current
homeless shelter beds that we have
or is this part of
this this is a separate item um
representative this is um
a reallocation or an extent an expansion
of an existing obligated source for the
youth residential services so what we're
trying to do with this item is use 10
million of the original 19 million that
was authorized
to get to a specific
subset of providers under this program
for
under 22 i believe under 25 years old
okay so it's
it was really in the original purpose of
the of the original item um but for
whatever reason through some sort of
uh lapse uh in the language we weren't
able to get it specifically to those
younger um those those locations that
serve younger populations okay so they
are different than our normal
uh homeless they're qualified is
different
in in a way that we need to have
additional authorization to get them
those resources okay fine fine are there
any further questions uh representative
earth
oh thank you madam chair
so i posed this question in the my
queries which apparently i don't know
did got 30 or not but related to what
grants because this is an ongoing
program and i was asking about what
grants have already been made into whom
etc i'm guessing your answer is going to
be it's on the website which is a good
answer could you provide us with it not
not right here in in
inver in words but could you email to mr
kane that website address it'd be easy
to look up this information
yeah i mean we could send you the
website for uh all the programs here
that'd be great thank you this program
here i'll just reiterate too is for
capital improvement uh components of uh
uh requests from these organizations but
i assume it's also the information is
also probably on the website as well i
with regard to the specific uh once they
are approved by council i believe that
that that will be up there right so
as i said that this is my understanding
is it's an ongoing program yes many
grants have already been authorized so
those will probably appear they've been
authorized they haven't been through
council yet they're coming up the next
meeting all right thank you
thank you
thank you yes are there further
questions
seeing none could i have please have a
motion
thank you uh senator rosenwald second
will the clerk please call the roll fis
representative edwards yes to 300
camerick votes
representative irf yes robertson
bleachman yes senator daniels yes
senator bradley yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator perkins
qualcomm yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is ten to zero the vote being
ten to zero
fis 300 passes
we now turn to fis 22 302
good morning steve lavoie director of
administration for the department of
safety
good morning
uh are there questions
from anyone
okay i do have just a couple of
questions mr lavoy
um
i saw your explanation about what you
have left out there
in um
in these variable
whatever they're called i assume that
those are the ones we see on the highway
that say
you know one death is too many we're at
99 or whatever it is
is this the sign boards that we're
talking about those are the sign boards
that we're talking about yes okay
and
you indicate that you loan these to
towns for
whatever
yeah so these are boards
that the division of emergency services
and communications maintains primarily
for emergency response
capabilities we use them for state
purposes coordinating with hsem if
they're needed but
locals can also request to to utilize
those boards they can put a request in
through the website form that's on the
hscm website
and those can be used locally
and
how
how long have you had the signs that are
now
not functional
we we've had them for
well over i want to say over 10 years uh
okay they've
they're they're signs that are out in
the elements in the weather they wear
out over time um
and we've been patching them together
and keeping them running as best as we
can but we continue to lose
functioning signs on a regular basis so
it's not like one or two years it's a
it's a long time it's been a while okay
thank you very much
second okay we have a motion by senator
gray to approve
seconded by uh
representative leishman
will the clerk please call the roll fis
302 representative edwards yes to 302.
hamrick votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator bradley yes senator
gray yes senator rosenwald yes senator
perkins walker yes representative
hamburger yes man i'm sure the vote is
ten to zero
the vote being twent ten to zero fis
from the department of health and human
services
good morning patricia tilley director of
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair and uh thank
you miss tilly for engaging with me
yesterday to um
prepare for some of this i
i
i i think new hampshire does a great job
one of the things we need to do i think
is
given some concerns about the cdc
coming out and admitting that oftentimes
they made policy up as they want without
the underlying science i i think that
it's incumbent upon us that when we do
something controversial and injecting
kids under five and
boosters over five turns out to be a
controversial issue i think it's
important for us
to
demonstrate that we're following the
science and so we have a policy before
us with six million dollars of funding
for the state to send mobile vaccines
out that's the policy
that policy should follow the science
would you summarize for us
what the science is that suggests
that the department has done the state's
due diligence to ensure that there's
published peer-reviewed research to
indicate that this is a safe and
efficacious way to go
thank you for that question um so what
we would say primarily i don't know that
i would necessarily agree with your
characterization of the cdc they have
had some communications issues and
others but we're not here to discuss
that in terms of the science of vaccine
the way new hampshire and in particular
public health and the department of
health and human services makes its
decision
is based on the data
we
led by dr chan who is our state
epidemiologist and leading infectious
disease expert he is charged with
reviewing all of the data all of the
peer-reviewed studies around safety and
efficacy some of the questions have been
around vaccine for children we have
monitored that data closely we have seen
that the current monovalent vaccines are
safe and effective in ensuring that kids
do not have the worst outcomes of
covid19 hospitalizations or even death
we know that in new hampshire that we've
been lucky we have only had one death of
a child during this pandemic while we've
had over 2 600 deaths through the great
through the adult population we continue
to have about a death a day
in the adult population of covenant 19.
covet has not gone away
so we are continuing to look at that
data we look at the broad effects from
both the efficacy of the vaccine itself
and balance that with the long-term
effects of covid19 in children we see
long-term effects even with those
smaller numbers we know that 20 to 29
year olds are actually the age group
that have coveted the most but the 10 to
19 year old population is is up there as
well um and we know that there are um
implications of essentially long covered
from children who have had coven 19
infections there are other outcomes from
myocarditis some impacts around diabetes
that are really concerning and so we
think it is effective policy in order to
have vaccine available to children and
to adults there's no requirement for
covid19 vaccine in school or child care
this is a decision that families can
make for themselves and individuals can
make for themselves as adults but it is
our job and it is our policy direction
that we think we should make vaccine as
easily available in every nook and
cranny around the state and our mobile
vaccine services help us we know that
last year
we administered almost 40 000 around 40
000 doses through our mobile vaccine
services so there was obviously a demand
communities asked us for the van we
deployed it there was no pushing of
vaccine this was in reaction to
the input from our community members we
were also able to vaccinate over 2 000
homebound individuals again individuals
that had limited access to get that
my follow-up
uh thank you madam chairman and uh thank
you for
that reply
i'm
glad that dr chan is reviewing all the
literature
is there a way to make available to the
public
a set of the literature that he's looked
at that specifically supports the idea
that
providing this vaccine to kids under
five
and boosters to those over five that
that is safe and efficacious and and
what i'm looking for there is actual
academic research that's been published
and peer reviewed
that so that the public can understand
and get a glimpse
into the decision process that that
we're going through on their behalf
thank you for that question we can
certainly look into what the best way to
share that data whether it's on our
website or others
i as the committee knows i shared a long
list a long literature review last night
looking at those very specific to around
a kid's vaccine but around the
efficaciousness of the of the vaccine
and also some of the other effects of
covid19 we can work with our
communications folks to determine the
best way that we can make that available
okay uh before you go on
i think that
um what
we're looking for
is
not a list of the studies
okay but rather
kind of a dr chan's summary
if that makes sense because
because
i don't know about
peop everybody but it would be nice to
have a summary and then if i want to go
someplace else i can do that sure we can
certainly provide that okay thank you
uh yes
uh
thank you man i'm sure and then on a
slightly separate topic um in the uh
it says that
the this program is necessary to help
students return to school
but the
services don't actually start until
october and so i as i remember school
kids they've already begun to go to
school so is this is just is this just
poorly written or or did we mean
something else
no i i think you know as you know we
prepare these documents long in advance
before they actually get to you um we
are um in short we want to um with these
funds we're going to bring them to if
approved today we will bring it to
governor and council at the end of the
month that's a little bit later than we
had originally anticipated but
regardless whether it's for kids to go
back to school or kids to stay in school
it's really important that we have
access to a vaccine i think we have all
felt anyone with a child in their life
the impact of having to have a child be
in isolation out of school and the
impact that it has on their caregivers
ability to work so i i think we could
word that differently but i think that's
an artifact of when we've actually
started writing the letter all right
thank you for that the reason i'm so
picky is because this goes to the public
and this is our communication and it's
important to maintain credibility and
one way to do that is to write precisely
so so that that's where i'm going with
that and and if there are no no other
questions man i'm sure i i'd be prepared
to approve but yeah okay representative
thank you madam chair
so why does the state
need to be involved in this vaccine
distribution and not others
a that's a really great question so i
think if you look at
childhood routine childhood vaccinations
we have a long established process by
which we provide free vaccines
vaccines for children to all providers
we have a complicated way in which we
work with the insurance companies in
order to fund that so that we can have
universal access to vaccine that is a
artifact of decades worth of work um and
there's a routine to getting that
vaccine
covid19 is still
supplied by the federal government again
separately than if i go to the
pharmaceutical market to get the other
vaccines that's a different process the
with the federal market we the
department of health and human services
receives a tranche of vaccines another
set of the vaccines go directly to some
of the partners like pharmacies there's
a direct federal relationship between
retail pharmacies the federal government
there's also a direct relationship in
other areas like federal corrections and
to a smaller degree federally qualified
health centers so we are essentially the
middle men in this particular vaccine
because of the way the federal
government has procured it
it is also um we are still in the middle
of a public health incident so we are
still managing this as an emergency we
certainly aren't using emergency powers
as we did early in the vac in the
vaccinate or the pandemic but we are
still controlling it on a day-to-day or
managing it on a day-to-day basis
ensuring that we get vaccines to the
right populations ensure that there's
equitable distribution everywhere
instead of just leaving it to the
okay
uh
senator daniels
thank you these services offered through
mobile are still being offered through
the pharmacy or have they been
discontinued no these services are also
available in pharmacy i think right now
those bivalent vaccines have just
started to land in the state and you can
get online and go to cvs and walgreens
and so if you are someone who's capable
and or willing to go through an app and
find a find a vaccine time and get
yourself there you can do that if that's
if that's the direction you want to go
what we found last year in particular
that we were ma
the mobile vans made it more convenient
for individuals an example i often use
is we were able to go to
work sites and again the work site did
not require the vaccine for its
employees but wanted to make it
available they understood the value in
keeping their own workers working and
many of the workers wanted to
participate and we were able to send the
van out in off hours for third shift
workers that's the sort of flexibility
that the van provides for us we can go
to a certain event that if they invite
us we can bring there and people can
then take that opportunity to get their
vaccine rather than trying to get an
appointment either at their provider or
at a retail pharmacy follow-up yes so
where does the
department uh find balance between
personal responsibility and
thinking that it's our job
to to go to somebody's door as opposed
to them uh taking the time to go to the
pharmacy on their own sure because there
is there is a cost to that there is a
cost and i think that's something that
we struggle with in in public health or
we balance every day of what's personal
responsibility and what's protective of
public health this particular strategy
not only protects individuals it also
protects the community we still have a
valid interest in ensuring that we
reduce and mitigate the spread of
covid19 i think we've all learned how
expensive those surges of covid19 are to
our workplaces who lose staff
to those who have to stay home we've
seen the implications over and over and
we certainly and right now as i noted
we're still having at least a person a
day die by covid19 it was the third
leading cause of death last year so
we're still making that balance
okay
are there any further questions
represent edwards uh thank you madam
chair as as you know i i wrestled with
making a motion a table um but i i'm not
going to do that i i just would
appreciate a much stronger commitment by
the department to have dr chan sign a
certifying that he's reviewed the
research and that he believes in his
professional opinion that this is safe
and efficacious for this these age
groups i i heard the department respond
to it in general but i didn't hear a
strong yes we will get it done we'll get
it done within a week i'd i'd like i'd
thank you i i i need to go back to the
team to determine which is what is the
best way we agree in in the intent of
what you're asking i think we can get
there i just don't know exactly what
that would look like in this moment
i i'm fine with that i i what i'm
looking for is is clear accountability
that we have an individual who says i've
done the research and and this is good
so that's that's what i'm looking for so
thank you for your patience
no problem
are there further questions comments
okay second
senator bradley moves uh representative
will the clerk please call the roll fs
304 representative edwards
yes
america votes yes representative erf no
representative leishman yes
senator bradley yes
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes senator perkins
yes representative umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is eight yes
two no
the vote being eight yes and two no
mis 22 304 passes
we now move on to fis-22305
from the department of health and human
services
uh dealing with a
with 15 million in
solution health so
welcome
good morning
red is on i guess yes
lori weaver deputy commissioner for the
department of health and human services
good morning
do you have any particular question you
want me to start with or would you like
me to just give a general overview to
start of the item why don't we start
with just a general overview i think
that would be helpful sure
um so this item here for solution health
when we look at whether the work of the
department over the last several years
of building a system of care
which is basically building services on
a continuum from least acuity need to
higher acuity need we've spent a lot of
time doing that
since covid the
increase in demand for higher acuity
services
has been there and over the last year
the commissioner has been out publicly
talking about working to find vendors to
work with us to meet those services
as you may recall back in january one of
those vendors was hca when we were here
to submit and accept and expend for that
money
unfortunately since that time we have
worked with hca and have not been able
to reach agreement so we're not able to
move forward at this time with hca
we are able however to present to you
the solution health which is really the
other vendor so
this vendor is coming to you now because
we're here in
in front of fiscal but we have been
talking with them for a while as well
and they are ready to move forward
um
it's the same prototype of a contract so
when we look at what we were asking for
hca and what we're asking for here it's
pretty much
the same
ask which is to offset the capital costs
for them to build services and in return
guarantee the state access to services
when we need them for that continuum of
care for higher acuity services
it is our plan that should this be
approved today that we would go to
governor and council
with our request for that grant which
would detail what we would ask the
vendor specifically to be doing in
addition to the accept and expend
most times we go to council for the
accept and expend and come back with the
contract we are going to do that all
together should this be approved here
today
are there any questions uh
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair and thank you miss weaver
for taking the question i
i
i would just ask you if you could help
clarify my understanding of the scenario
here when
we approved essentially saying this it's
essentially the same deal as we offered
hca now we're offering uh solution
health which i understand is somehow
affiliated with elliott
when when when we cast that vote i could
have sworn that we were told that hca
had been identified because we had done
our due diligence in the state and
nobody else had wanted to to bid or
participate in an offer like that
and so to find ourselves a few months
later
now with elliot basically uh saying that
they'd be open to this i'm i'm i'm
curious did did did the situation evolve
did we not do the right homework up
front
i'm just curious about that that gap
from going from only hca is willing to
do this to finding a replacement and i'm
happy about it by the way
sure i
i believe in in in terms of doing our
due diligence i believe that we did do
that and we did have two interested
parties at the time hca was the one that
was able to come forward first with and
and be able to get to a point where we
could ask for an acceptance spend um
solution health at that time hadn't
materialized so the commissioner has
said publicly several times that we were
looking at two vendors that could meet
are there further quotes senator
rosenwald thank you madam chair
i'm just can you clarify
whether the
25 drf beds
would be a net ad or is elliot planning
to close its
drf beds and move them to this new
facility i'm sure marissa do you wanna
and the other beds too the voluntary
beds
i think
sure so um based on the letter of intent
and discussions that we've had to date
um you'll see on page on page three of
the item we have the the the inpatient's
bed listed there um we have listed 25
beds which is essentially doubling the
existing capacity obviously we couldn't
exactly you know it's not doubling
because it's 12.5
um but but it as i understand it it
would be a net increase at this point
however
ultimately um you know the final figures
would be
determined through negotiations in in
the final agreement
so the elliot is not closing its
inpatient units
and
using that space to do
something
well then
not to my knowledge no would we be
requiring that
i i think as nathan had said i think we
would go through an occasion
negotiations won't know that but i don't
think we're planning on requiring
anybody to close anything what we're
requiring is access to services that we
don't currently have
through that vendor
thank you i wasn't thinking we would
require elliott to close their beds i
was hoping maybe we would require them
to keep them open i see that as of
yesterday
we had 35 adults
waiting for
an emergency bed so
we haven't solved
the er boarding crisis
despite approving
lots of millions of dollars
giving solution health this money and
saying you have to keep these beds open
or are we
not
so if it would be helpful i i can speak
to sort of what we're envisioning for
the larger agreement and and how that
would work if you think that would
helpful because it kind of feeds into
your question if you would like that
i mean yes go ahead i think we are all
interested in sure solving the er
boarding crisis i know we
approved money for all the hospitals to
open drf beds there were no takers
this time
the
hca plan didn't move forward
i'm hopeful about
this proposal i know
the elliott and southern are interested
but
we have some leverage
with this money and i'm just
hoping
and that the department will use that
leverage and wondering
if you're going to
yes so so we we fully intend to so the
agreement itself is going to look a
little different than many of the
contracts that we typically have
um in this case it would
it would likely be an agreement that has
two major phases and the first phase is
the construction phase so during at
which point the
solution health would incur construction
costs they would submit in invoices we'd
reimburse them for qualified payments
after that once the facility would be
ready to go live and start accepting
patients that's where we envision
a a 10 potentially 12-year commitment
where they would be required to ensure
certain levels of service and there'd be
required quarterly monthly annual
potentially biannual reporting
requirements based upon the specific
terms of those
of that agreement we would also um
ensure that there would be clawback
provisions so that if certain levels of
services were not provided
we would have the ability to claw back
some of those funds
and or extend the length of the contract
we're
as as we've been looking at this
agreement we've consulted with many
different individuals to make sure that
whatever the final agreement looks like
it will ensure that a we have long-term
access to services for the state and b
we have the ability
to take action if if necessary if the
required services that have been
outlined within that agreement are not
met
are there any further questions
yes senator daniels thank you
on page three your justification for
this capital s
seems to be based upon
the the covet blip which
tends to be an anomaly
in the whole course of things so my my
question here is
uh
since you're basing this
on that period of time what are you
doing
to
uh
address
what happened
during during covid so that it doesn't
happen again and
does that maybe necessitate not the need
for such a
large facility or or the services that
thank you senator daniels marissa hen
associate commissioner dj jess
i think it's interesting when we think
about an event like
covid because we don't yet know how long
the impacts
um on a population level when it comes
to behavioral health how long that will
last we know from other
mass events that affect populations
things like hurricane katrina et cetera
that oftentimes the impacts from a
emotional psychological distress
standpoint can last for decades so
many of our local and national and
international indicators are suggesting
that we may have an increased prevalence
and acuity of behavioral health need for
a very long time to come that said i
think you raise an important question
which is how do we not restrict this
just to the covid phenomenon but also
build on all the important work that's
been going on across the state to
address behavioral health needs and i
think to the deputy commissioner's point
this is building on the 10-year mental
health plan and the system of care work
to really ensure that we have a
continuum of services
that we're offering of course still
committing to that community-based
objective of serving people in their
homes in their communities when possible
but recognizing there remains a need for
that sort of tip of the pyramid level of
acute
acute care services and that that needs
to be provided in more than one facility
um and and of course that you know to
the question of of hampstead having
these beds for children for example not
just at hampstead but also offering it
at a peer facility is a particular
are there any further questions
seeing none could i
senator bradley
uh moves
fis-22305
will the clerk please call the roll
fis305 representative edwards yes to
305. kimray chess representative irf yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator bradley yes senator
gray yes senator rosenwald yes senator
perkins cuoco yes representative
umberger yes madam chair the vote is
10-0 the vote being 10-0 fis-22305
passes
we now turn to
312.
are there
any questions from um
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair and it's just an observation
that uh this
has the same issues as the prior three
that i isolated there's there's nothing
it's 252 000 it's not a great deal of
money but uh when you read the
explanation there's nothing uh
quantitative in here to give us an
understanding of exactly what this 252
is going to do what if we're going to
spend money what does the end state look
like what is our goal what's our
objective is it measurable those are the
kinds of things i think the fiscal
committee needs to know about
and i'm i'm not going to oppose this i
just wanted to make that point again
senator rosenwald thank you
i was sort of a chicken in a question
you state in the narrative that
birth centers are maybe increasing their
deliveries because
families are choosing not to have births
in a hospital setting but to what extent
are we seeing
this being influenced by the number of
hospitals that are closing their
birthing units
thank you thank you patricia tilly again
director of public health thank you for
that question senator we're not sure
right now i think that that requires a
little bit more study and a lot more
detail of understanding where the
individuals come from who have those
births so it's not surprising that many
of those freestanding birth centers are
in some of the more densely populated
areas of state so they would still have
access as opposed to
the birth closures that we've really
seen cut across the middle of new
hampshire um oddly enough if you if you
know route 11 that goes east west it's
roughly along route 11 that's where
we've seen the first round of big
closures from claremont all the way to
the eastern part of the state we have
some closures up north um
so you know we would need to do more
digging to figure out which we've just
looked at right now and we've certainly
seen the numbers that all births in new
hampshire have gone up in 2020 and 2021
new hampshire was one of the only states
to have an increase in births in 2021 so
it's hard to pull apart if this is just
an artifact of it's the same proportion
that are going or if we're seeing a real
increase we know anecdotally what we've
heard from the birth centers is that
people are saying it was because of
covid it was about a more personalized
experience it was about being able to
bring people especially in 2021 where
you couldn't bring
supportive partners to the birth all of
that has contributed to some of their
growth but i can't tell you definitively
quick follow-up thank you i knew that at
some point the state was paying
an enhanced
payment to um
androscoggin valley correct to keep
their ob unit open are we still doing
that and are we doing that to any other
hospital well thank you yes it is my
understanding i am not henry lipman
but i can tell you that we are still
providing that enhanced payment to
andrew scoggin luckily with support of
the legislature we were able to have an
increase in all rates for birth centers
and in particular among those rural
areas so we're looking forward to that
at moving forward to have some increased
rates for everyone but androscoggin has
historically kept that rate they have a
rel you know if we were to lose
androscoggin that would be a huge
senator daniels
thank you in the course of doing
business i i would look at
insurance premiums in this case
malpractice
premiums as a
an ongoing operating expense and so my
ques my question is uh what's the
justification of using one-time money
through opera funds to to pay for
operating expense which are ongoing as
opposed to one-time cost thank you
senator dalios i think that's a very
fair question one of the health center
one of the birth centers reported to us
and reported to gopher that their
malpractice insurance had typically been
from about twenty four thousand dollars
rose in one year to sixty eight thousand
dollars their volume is so small that
they were unable to keep you know that
would be a rounding error in many other
businesses but that was enough to can
have them consider closing their doors
so i think this is a stop gap measure
for two years to help them get back on
their feet we have some increased rates
coming forward for the birth centers so
that should be able to equal that
that balance of being able to provide
one-time support and then support it
with ongoing
reimbursements from commercial and
uh so you state that in the event the
federal funds are no longer available
that general funds will not be used but
i just heard you say that you'll be
asking for more that basically would
take the place of general of federal
funds
uh i i would not characterize that
exactly as being so the general funds
are going to take the place we are those
rates were artificially low and so those
rates are rising to regular um closer to
what it actually costs to do business i
don't know if you want to answer that um
i i i i think the
that statement is specific to this
program here which is specific to
targeting the malpractice insurance rate
increases and not necessarily to the
medicaid rate program we were thinking
about those separately in that statement
so are we actually playing a shell game
so that when the federal funds stop the
malpractice insurance is still high so
you're just moving
moving
money
from the general fund that you get now
over to cover the malpractice insurance
and asking for more through the general
fund
i don't necessarily think i would
characterize it in in that manner i mean
the way that the way that we were
envisioning this
um in conversations with with gopher and
and others was that this would be as as
director tilly pointed out this would be
the one time stop gap measure um the the
the rates have been uh increased that
was approved by the legislature this
past session
um so we we we kind of see these things
as two separate items i don't know if i
would characterize it in the same way
no i i mean i think what we would see
with any rates it covers the broad
spectrum of costs associated with doing
business malpractice is one particular
one part of that but it's across the
board all of whether the professional
service fees and the other fees that are
required to to do business so as um as
noted the fees are to support ongoing
costs this is a one-time effort to
address this one big leap in malpractice
are there any further questions
yes said representative
okay thank you madam chair uh throughout
the day i've pointed out four of these
requests that i i thought needed
stronger quantitative analysis and i
just didn't want to leave it without
giving you an example of what i'm
talking about so if you look at 314 we
did not
you don't have to do it now but
when you
we're not pulling it off the calendar in
large part because whoever ghost wrote
this for the commissioner's signature
did a fairly nice job in that last
paragraph given us some numbers that we
can begin to wrap our head around so so
i wanted to give you an example of of of
the kind of thing that would be helpful
in the future so
i didn't want to just be negative this
this is a positive thing this is what
i'm looking for
sure and maybe we can have a
conversation offline about you know some
some better details and you know
outcomes and whatnot that you're looking
for
okay um are there any further questions
seeing none
move the item uh representative leishman
moves do i have a
seconded by senator bradley
well the clerk please call the role on
fis 312. wreath fis 312 representative
edwards yes to 312. america s earth
river
yes representative leishman yes senator
daniels no
uh senator bradley yes
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins cuoco yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair the vote is nine yes one no
the vote being nine in favor and one
opposed
we now turn to fis 22
again health and human services
dealing with
are there questions from the committee
senator bradley
uh
thank you very much i just wanted to um
get into the record the conversation
that we had the other day
which i believe addressed all of my
concerns
um when the senate looked at this idea
of
providing funding for homeless services
we did it in a different manner
mainly because many of the small towns
in new hampshire have limited options in
terms of services especially in the
northern part of the state so i wanted
and the senate i think wanted to ensure
that
for those towns that
the only real option for them is to
place
homeless individuals in motel or hotel
rooms that
this
would allow for that kind of service the
million dollars to be utilized in that
manner
i'm on okay
i can't figure this out um thank you for
that question um senator bradley chris
santaniello associate commissioner and
yes that would be allowed within the
funds that we allocate
further yes please go ahead and so a
town like conway which both uh the chair
and i represent that we know
um have folks that are
homeless right now
when the cold weather
comes the town of conway for instance
i'm just using it as a for instance
would be able either through a
not-for-profit agency or directly to
come to the department and be able to
thank you senator bradley my name is
karen hebert i'm the director for the
division of economic and housing
stability so yes uh for example the
way uh path
uh organization up in conway that is
trying to seek further funding for their
program that would be
very applicable to this
for this funding that would they be able
to strengthen their program there so
looking at just those uh those
organizations throughout each county and
their unique needs that would meet that
so it if i might madam chair yes please
the town of conway then could work with
waypoint or the carroll county
the county um to access these funds to
be able to utilize
motel accommodations if that's what the
best
option was yes absolutely
perfect thank you
are there further questions uh
representative leishman
thanks madam chair thanks for your
explanations but
i'm reading through your
letter that you have and you talk about
the number of shelters available or beds
in the state and it's far not sufficient
for the ones we need but i also noted
that you do not provide any funding for
temporary cold weather
sure um chris santaniello again um
that's just not a program that the
department has um
had funding for typically
that
occurs through um you know municipal
dollars community fundraisers but we
have very limited dollars um in this
program area and so we use it for
year-round shelters
okay but i thought it said some of this
money could be used for the cold weather
shelters
yes um we're gonna do it's divided up we
have allocated a million dollars for
that yes okay but typically we don't
fund those okay and
are there further questions uh
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair i
i expect that 313 is going to pass in an
overwhelming way and so i want to
explain why i'm going to vote no it's
got nothing to do with the department
has done it's simply a process issue uh
the the the basic outline of this
proposal was with the other body in the
legislature
at the beginning of the term
it was held within that body
and never sent over to the house so the
house policy committee has been excluded
from reviewing and approving of this
policy i think they may have
but
in order to
make the point
that
we have a bicameral system and this had
an opportunity to go to the house for
review and it wasn't uh i'll i'll be
voting no
because uh this is this is a process
crime in my view not a crime but that's
that's just a saying
it's a it's a process foul how's that
all right so
thanks okay uh thank you
uh further comments questions
um i do know that uh folks are anxious
to um
know how to apply
for this money
do you have any idea how long it will be
until
something can come out
we are working on expediting that
process right now so hopefully
it would just be a matter of weeks
and i assume the application would be on
the website
i'm sorry i didn't hear you the
application would be on the website oh
yes okay thank you
any other questions
senator bradley moves to approve
will the clerk call the role
we'll call fs313
representative edwards no on thirteen
american folks yes representative erf
yes representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator bradley yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins quoca yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair the voters nine yes one no
the vote being nine
to one
fis
we now turn to fis 315
which
is sort of related to 317 that we
passed earlier
but um if i could
this is from the
welcome back
good to see you
yes yes
are there um
questions i see uh represent rosenwald
okay are there any further questions
that were not answered when we discussed
um
okay seeing none
is there anything you would like to add
no ma'am i appreciate your interest
oh okay thank you
all right so
uh second
senator rosenwald move seconded by
senator daniels
this is on fis 3 22 315.
well the clerk please call the roll
fis 315 representative edwards
yes the 315. hamrick votes yes
representative earth yes represent
leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator bradley yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins coca yes representative
umber yes man i'm sure the vote is ten
to zero the vote being ten to zero fis
we now turn to fis
22 316
also from uh
not the gopher
so
um
are there any questions uh
senator rosenwald thank you
just curious if
the business
goes out of business is the state in any
way on the hook
to repay the federal government for
those funds no ma'am so we have no risk
are there any further questions
uh representative erf
uh thank you madam chair
do you have any idea why so many
businesses fell into this
recruitment
yes well first of all i mean i should go
back
to the underlying programs uh that this
is sort of helping us get to the end of
back in cair's act under main street
relief fund and the there was a
self-employed program
there was around 500 million dollars
of aid that went under those programs uh
to businesses across the state
to roughly 12 000
small businesses um
over the course of uh time in in early
april 2021
uh we did see that there were going to
be some businesses that were going to
fall into the recoupment category under
the federal rules
um
through a series of programs we've now
gotten that down to fi uh roughly about
um of uh small businesses left of those
original
12 000 not all of them obviously face
recruitment but you know we're down to
basically 98 percent of the program is
in a situation where there's no
recruitment
necessary so it really is at the end
we're giving a final option for
businesses to take to choose if they so
choose uh to extend the ability to repay
whatever they uh might owe
uh under the recoupment requirements for
a period of two years at zero percent
interest so this is like the the very
follow-up
but you didn't quite answer my question
and maybe you can't which if you can't
that's fine but i'm just curious as to
why did so many businesses maybe i
shouldn't say so many why did businesses
why did they fall into this recruitment
well i mean the simple answer is that a
lot of businesses did better than they
had anticipated they would do when they
when they applied for the initial
program so if you call the way the
program worked was that we asked
businesses to project what they
anticipated losses were going to be over
the course of the next couple of months
and we paid a percentage of that which i
believe under most programs around 17 of
their projected losses we gave them a
grant in that amount
there were businesses however that ended
up
not
losing the amount of money that they
anticipated they would have that they
would have lost
and so that put them in a situation
where we had to offer them options to
offset that and we did that through
programs like offsetting with covet
expenditures we did that with a
recruitment program where there was
another brand they could credit against
what those uh what the potential
recruitment was and that's how we got it
down to the 300 number that we're at
right now
thank you yeah
yes uh represent representative lynn
thank you can i ask you do
we is there has there been some effort
made to ensure will there be some effort
made to ensure that
before we're you know giving sort of
loan
loans to some of these companies that
there's not
that they're not sort of under
investigation by
by the either the attorney general's
office or the feds to be for some kind
of
fraudulent activity and in connection
with the original loans yes sir
absolutely and that's something we
monitor very very closely
um thankfully we've not had many cases
in those categories but that would
absolutely be part of uh any review
that we would be doing
to
are there further questions
thank you senator bradley
uh will the clerk please call the roll
uh represent petrie would you please
roll call fs
316.
emory coach yes
representative earth yes representative
leishman yes representative petry
senator daniels yes
senator bradley yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins cuoco yes
representative umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
the vote being ten to zero um
fis
passes
and tab eight is fis-294
i know you've spent a lot of time with
us this week and uh
there's just one more
i'm excited to be back i thought so okay
uh would you mind uh just
giving us a brief overview of uh
of what you're looking for please not at
all so thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record john from l
attorney general and i'm joined by kathy
carr our director of administration
so this is the request that we bring
before the fiscal committee one
sometimes more times per year for funds
in our litigation fund
the litigation fund is used to to
support the department's efforts to both
defend the state and civil litigation
and um
prosecute
so
uh
for our criminal bureau um enforce the
state's criminal laws it's used to
support the environmental protection
bureau which enforces the state's
environmental laws it's used to support
our criminal uh our consumer protection
bureau
which enforces our consumer protection
laws we do both civil and criminal work
in the consumer protection bureau
and um
it
it is meant
meant to be used sort of as a supplement
when we have needs at the department
that go beyond
what our internal resources can can
support
this is a larger request
than normal
so that goes without saying this is a
particularly large request
and i think that stems from a couple of
things and it's multiple factors but but
two primary factors
one is that i think the state is dealing
with more complex civil litigation at
the moment than it typically deals with
i'll go through it but that that
consists of of ydc
and the litigation associated with that
it consists of
a major school funding case
one that is much closer to trial and
that's now been paired with the second
school funding school funding lawsuit
that was filed earlier this year
consists of two major major federal
court cases in which we're defending the
department of health and human services
multiple cases regarding redistricting
and election law and and the list goes
on but the department is dealing with
more complex civil litigation right now
than it typically deals with
it's also not just about the number
of cases that the department's dealing
with it's about where those cases are
in the process so the further you move
along in a case the further you move
through discovery the closer you get to
trial if they're complex cases the costs
the the funding needs at any time um get
higher
depending on where you are in the case
and so it's not just that we have more
complex civil litigation but we have a
few cases that are that have come to a
point where they require some some
significant funding so that that's one
general reason i think why this is a
larger request than normal and the
second is that
the department has and i won't go
through the entire organizational chart
but we have a lot of internal resources
we do a lot of different
things but
one
kind of general function of the
department of justice is to assist every
state agency in state government we
represent every state agency we give
legal advice we lend support
and
i think across state government
as we all know
we've seen challenges with recruitment
and retention and that puts a lot of
burden on state agencies and because we
serve every state agency
we
uh i think agencies require more support
from us than normal and so we're using
our internal resources for that and
internal resources that we use for that
client counseling function cannot be
used for litigation so those are two
i wanted to just give that overview to
sort of explain why this is a larger
request than normal i think those are
those are two factors that contribute
contribute to that so with that i'll
just walk through the major cases that
we're talking about
uh i'm not sure that's necessary okay uh
you you pretty much
put that in the thing so uh other
senator roosevelt
thank you madam chair just a question on
the smallest thing in here
the uh election law do you expect or
have you already hired any outside
counsel
on either of these two redistricting
cases or is this
incurred in-house
we have not and i
i think the expenses we're expecting
there are for for experts and potential
expert testimony we have not retained
outside counsel for those redistricting
cases i
it's possible we may but at this point
my goal and my intent is to use in-house
resources for those cases
are there any further uh representative
leishman thanks man of chair uh thank
you attorney general is it fair to say
that some of the recoveries or
settlements that you've received lately
would more than cover
this request the funds that you've
received
yes i mean those recoveries don't go
into the litigation fund but i i think
it is fair to say that the department
has brought in far more money in this
calendar year through settlements and
recoveries than this litigation fund
request
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
approve move the item thank you
uh
representative leishman and seconded by
well the clerk please call the roll
we'll call on fis
294. hamrick folks yes representative
earth yes represent leishman yes
representative petry yes
senator daniels yes senator bradley yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins cuoco yes
representative umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is 10-0
thank you very much thank you
fis
and um
fis22319
from the department of administrative
services
uh
i believe that we can talk about
319 and 320
together
since one is the program and the others
the money
commissioner
um
okay
so
um
i want to emphasize uh i'm charlie
erlinghouse i'm the commissioner of
administrative services
and i'm sherry rockburn i'm the
assistant commissioner
um
i've got so i i want to emphasize a
couple things there are a bunch of
different things in this package
so we're here performing more of a
ministerial function so i can talk about
the what and the why there's a whole
host of commissioners and commandants
behind me who will
no doubt explain all of that to you why
it's essentially a group of recruitment
and retention packages for um
for a variety of officials
um state police
um there's a few um
uh people at the fire academy i'm gonna
get that wrong
fire safety
personnel
correctional personnel
veterans home personnel
and there's also a i left somebody out
nurses generally across state government
and then in addition to that
there's a winner maintenance retention
program so think of highway maintainers
but that program will be extended to
other people in state government who
have a cdl
so people who don't normally participate
in winter maintenance could
if they chose and they have a cdl a
commercial driver's license participate
it's a sum of recruitment
packages which was i think discussed
sort of a
significant conversation between various
people in the governor's office and
various people in
in these agencies um
who will uh who'll be affected by this
in ways to both retain personnel and in
the case of
retention
retention payments and in the case of
recruitment payments a lot of
people like correction officers for
example
have an opportunity to get a bonus if
they go somewhere else
and this will allow us to keep them
the commonality i believe between all of
these items is that they are
functioning 24 7 facilities
as opposed to anything else
and i'll just note that there's nobody
in my department
okay uh yes uh senator roosevelt thank
you
my question is really specifically about
the retention
piece
my understanding this is one time money
that
is pretty significant it looked to me
like ten thousand dollars per person it
think what happens
at the end of that
when the individual's compensation
goes back down by ten thousand dollars
are we going to see
people
leaving state government
um and what do you think we're going to
end up
needing to do
on the
ongoing compensation
and i realized that you don't get to
negotiate
the contracts but
what do you think is going to happen to
the vacancy rate
when people see their compensation fall
off
i think um
i want to emphasize that it's not it's
not pay uh i mean it is pay but it's not
uh ongoing in your paycheck it's a it's
a payment in some case a one-time
payment or in some cases a two payment
tranches
um and um so it really is in the effect
of a
it'll feel like a bonus as opposed to a
um
ongoing compensation increase
i think it's um for any employer the the
challenge with um paying things like
bonuses
um to sign on you know five thousand
dollars to work at dunkin donuts it's
probably not five thousand at dunkin
donuts but
uh but significant um is yeah what
happens then do people do people shop
around a year later and and i think
that's going to be a question i think
historically if you look at you know and
i don't have data on this but
historically if you look at things like
um like signing on bonuses
um they tend to occur in times where
there's a particularly tight labor
market
and not be an ongoing basis there's not
a reset they they
they go in waves and they tend to go in
waves everywhere that is to say
tons and tons of employers are offering
them and then tons and tons of employers
are not because the labor market loosens
and
and i think that's where we would be
i don't honestly think the state
government can this is extraordinary
quite possibly unprecedented in our in
our history
and um
it's sort of a you know a storm of a
of a particularly tight labor market
right now
and the availability of arpa funding
and though both of those two things are
quite unusual
and the likelihood of them appearing at
the same time again you know are before
and and another tight labor market is
slim so i don't think it'll happen again
and i think it's probably incumbent upon
most managers to explain to employees
that
that this is unusual and this probably
representative perkins quoca
thank you chairwoman you got it exactly
right um
thank you commissioner and i guess just
as a quick follow-up to senator
roosevelt's question i mean
yes this is absolutely an extraordinary
um labor market that said as a housing
advocate um you know i've been listening
to our businesses talk about a shortage
of workers for years now so
you know i think the question goes more
to
this may be a one-time program but in
the long term i mean the state
government may benefit and i i guess i'm
asking for your opinion here in in
seeing higher wages just to ensure that
we are um
you know retaining
retaining talent at the state level and
not seeing turnover at a place where
institutional knowledge is really valued
i i think it's probably very important
uh you know my understanding and you
know i can't speak for the governor or
the bargaining team or any of that
but my understanding is that um
you know this is a program to deal with
one subset of state workers but there's
a general recognition that state workers
broadly speaking
have greater issues and some of that's
related to things like inflation you
know when when inflation is one one and
a half two percent people don't pay a
lot of attention to it
when it's nine
and you kind of do i'm thinking a lot
more about my oil payments than i did
the last couple years
um
and so i think that's a thing and i
think without question we need to figure
out ways to better ways to attract
talent and there's no question that
wages are part of that
housing is also part of that i mean it
i'd i'll note that on the
governing council agenda
yesterday or
whenever we were on top of mount
washington
um the air was thin i don't remember
well um
somebody resigned from a position and
one of the things they said was that you
know it's really hard to buy a house and
so they're going to move to wyoming
and we probably need a little bit less
uh
would you like to discuss the
total money part
which is in 320
i'm sorry can you say that again yeah
hearing's bad 320
is uh
is dealing with the money yes
sherry can you walk through the money
quickly
i think the most helpful
chart or table to look at
is
the money on page or the table on page
12 of 13.
it takes up almost the whole page in the
packet
i think that's a really good summary
though of the programs
and
and the funding so i'll give you a
minute if you have that page open
you'll notice that the first
you know six or seven items are all
funded with arpa funding
and that is 13 just under 13.5 million
and you'll see two numbers on the bottom
the winner maintenance programs through
the department of transportation and
those funding is coming 4.3 million is a
transfer from highway surplus
and around 400 000
from the turnpike general reserve
account
so that's the the breakdown
13-5 coming from arpa and
just under five million
is from uh transportation highway and
turnpike funding and that's strictly on
the winner maintenance is where turnpike
funding is coming into play and highway
i i would just note that this this
particular chart
sherry did obviously not me
in response to my
18 different questions which used a
different number for the total each time
and i think she realized that
if my little p brain could get confused
look at other people's
and uh and when when she was up until
midnight at the office doing this
at some one of those late hours she came
up with this chart and i think it's
remarkably helpful at least to me
um the only other thing i would add to
that is under the initiative i can just
talk real high level about the incentive
programs that fall under that it doesn't
have the dollars with it but i can just
very quickly kind of go through that so
the first item um the safety
for the new full-time state police sworn
personnel
that is a
ten thousand dollar bonus
paid as soon as practical upon higher so
that's a lump sum that happens at the
front end of that hiring they do have to
sign an agreement that says they will
stay in that position or similar
position for up to one year
um subject to payback at the end of that
year if they choose to to leave
state service or take a position that's
not related to the one that they were
hired into
the
next one down is for the existing sworn
personnel at state police
and existing is also 10 000 but that is
paid in two lump sum payments a 5 000 um
within a as soon as practical upon this
uh passage and then a second payment um
in
march april springtime period i don't
have the exact date on that but that's
two lump sum payments um 5 000 each
um
the
uh third one down for safety is the fire
safety area there's about nine positions
that are in that that follows the same
new any new hire would be the 10 000 up
front the one underneath it is for
existing and that is 5000 split um
sort of fall spring
then you'll see that corrections has
both a new and existing they follow that
same logic a new correctional sworn
personnel 10 000 and then a 5 000 split
um correctional also has a little bit
different item here this is a retention
incentive it's a 15 enhancement
for their nurses their direct care
nurses at the institution at their
correctional facilities
nurses currently have a 15 this is an
additional 15 percent that they'll get
for a one year period
normally enhancements
only go through the governor and council
process so new hampshire hospital has an
enhancement uh glencliff home sununu
youth center
so that normally
agencies fund within their existing
budget so it's not something that
normally fiscal would see it usually is
just a government council item
corrections can't absorb this increase
within their existing budget so they've
asked for arpa funding to approve that
additional 15 but all the other
institutions that have the nurses at the
governor council meeting on wednesday
received approval to have that
additional 15 percent so they they look
a little different but it's just because
of their funding stream
uh the veterans home um this is a two
thousand dollar
payment to all of the staff at the
veterans home for full-time there's a
500 payment for part-time
back in june the veterans home received
approval through fiscal of a retention
program through frisco and gnc
for direct care to receive this
incentive payment
this is for the non-direct care staffing
at the veterans home
and this would be payable in november
time period as a lump sum payment
that's the sum of all the arpa funding
and then the last two on transportation
that is a five thousand dollar in total
payment and that is split 2500 at the
beginning of the winter maintenance
period and then uh 2500 at the end of
the winter maintenance period it would
get pro-rated for anyone that gets hired
in between and doesn't either uh isn't
there for the entire winter maintenance
period which is runs about november 1st
through um early april
so that's sort of a
high level summary of the individual
items and then the funding that goes
with it thank you are there any
questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
and
fis320
okay
senator bradley
well the clerk please call the roll
okay this is for fis 319 and 320.
emirate votes yes representative irf yes
represent leishman yes representative
petrie yes senator daniels yes senator
bradley yes senator gray yes senator
rosenwald yes senator perkins cuoco yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair of the vote on 319 and 320
is 10-0 okay
the vote being 10 to 0 on
fis-22 319 and
fis-320
both pass
uh this is public school infrastructure
sure madam chair that's 303 i think it's
possibly just the stamp yeah okay
sorry
uh
for the record frank edelblut
commissioner of education
a felon read department of safety
uh would you just give us
three sentences on the program
then we'll
sure so this is a program to
improve the security in our school
buildings
the programs are primarily focused on
act go ahead access
three categories access control
emergency alerting and surveillance
and the first round of funding all
public schools were eligible to apply
and we had
about 3.8 million dollars left over from
the original public school
infrastructure fund
the account earned a little bit of
interest because there was 3.3 but now
we're up to 3.8 and some change
so this is to award 177
applications to 92 different schools
okay
thank you sure there is um if i made the
second round of funding that's um 10
million dollars
that uh we're working through those
applications but what's before you is
for the first round of applications
okay
the object was to get it out the door as
quickly as possible yes ma'am right
the public school infrastructure
representative leishman thank you madam
chair
and thanks for your
good brief just
brief discussion
so i
looked back the department presented at
some
length a 42-page document showing other
grants for security enhancements and i
noticed in that particular
document there were some issues like
hudson got 300 000 for a sprinkler
system under the same program now most
of the items were for security cameras
doors locks
now in your request are there any
uh outside of security
issues or are they all for security
right so that first tranche of funding
was used for safety which included some
safety measures security measures as
well as some
truthfully
broadband measures as well there were
some awards for that in there as well
this is specifically for security only
so these projects are going to be
limited to those three categories that
fallon had mentioned
and just one follow-up madam chair
please go ahead thanks
i noticed in your request this time for
instance salem was looking for maybe a
208 thousand dollars and they got a
hundred thousand dollars because you set
a cap of a hundred thousand dollars and
yet there were a number of other
smaller schools i'll take my community
there's a charter school and they were
looking for like 96 or 98 000
how did you determine
who gets what where the cap came from
because for a small school to get safe
the 90s somewhat thousand dollars
but salem with a much greater school
population they only got a hundred
thousand on their request
sure so i can speak to how we did the
risk ranking um but the commission
decided to do the hundred thousand
dollar cap so once we received all the
applications my office at emergency
management reviewed each of the
applications and we had five questions
that were part of the application that
helped us do the risk ranking and
depending on the answer they either got
one point or no points and
so the highest potential score was a 7.0
and the lowest that was uh given was a
2.0 and then we had an average of 5.9 so
we had based
the
questions were pretty standard have you
submitted an emergency operations plan
within the last 12 months has your
school had an assessment completed by
emergency management
how many security assessments have your
school had
since we started the program in 2014
a reference to
emergency drills how many of them have
been
emergency all hazards
and then have you submitted your current
floor plans to first responders so that
allowed us to
do the scoring have a risk ranking and
then we had categories or tiers that we
looked at for the score so
there were five different tiers
the application scoring below average
in the categories of access control and
emergency alerting were put first so we
did as many applications as we could at
that point with the cap of a hundred
thousand
and then we looked at tier two which was
application scoring below 5.0
in surveillance and then we went there
so we kept going down to the different
tiers until we reached the cap of the
3.8 million dollars
okay thanks thanks madam chair
seeing none could i have a motion please
thank you senator daniels second
will the clerk please call the roll
fis 203.
real three
this book's got two or three
it's oh i'm sorry it's a typo okay
sorry about that there's a have a typo
but that's all right all right this is
303.
emery vote chess representative irf yes
representative leishman yes
representative petry yes senator daniels
yes
senator bradley yes senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator perkins quoca yes representative
omburger yes
and i'm sure the vote is 10 to zero
passes
uh from the
nathan white dhhs cfo
karen heber director division of
okay
um
let me get to the right place
uh are there any questions
that um
[Music]
anyone has represent earth
thank you madam chair
so other than
moving the cliff
to a higher income threshold bringing
more people onto food stamps how does
the intent is that so individuals could
continue to pursue employment or pursue
a promotion in employment where they
would increase their income but
oftentimes that isn't quite enough
to
be able to continue strengthening their
own economic condition so what this does
is still enable them to be eligible for
snap benefits
that way they can continue to strengthen
their own position with that added
income
then slowly be able to
instead of suddenly not being eligible
any longer for those benefits
and experiencing that loss they'd be
able to just use that extra income
over time to be able to just strengthen
so i think that and i understand that
that's moving the cliff
but that doesn't take away the cliff
effect correct they're just going to run
into the cliff a little bit higher up in
their income
i would characterize it more as
reducing or mitigating the cliff
not necessarily eliminating the cliff
this is an attempt to try to
reduce that sudden loss of those
benefits
so i'm not sure that
there are particular actions that can
completely eliminate the cliff but this
represent lynn yes can i ask you just
ask a question the the the the limit
right now is uh is am i correct is 180
of the poverty level is that 185 185 i'm
sorry and and that 185 was established
how does how did that get established
uh that's a good question i believe it
was set into law and i don't know the
history of that but i could certainly
find that out and get that for you so
when you i guess do you know maybe did
you know this at
this point was it when you say it was
set into law was that by the state
legislature or the feds i believe the
state has the discretion of determining
the eligibility which is why we're able
to change the percentage now through
this process okay so i i guess the only
question i have and it's really sort of
a process
question maybe
addressed to everyone really is if the
legislature set the
set the current limit at 185
i guess i raised the question of
is it appropriate for this body
uh which represents only a very small
percentage of the whole legislature to
change the
the number from 185 to 200.
sure so um i i guess to start um i'd
like just to go back to hb2 from this
past session
um there was a provision in there
chapter 91 section 34 that specified
that
any any modifications to that threshold
um would need to be both approved uh by
the house and human services and elderly
affairs committee as well as the fiscal
committee and that's that's why we're
here before you today um chris
centenello just reminded me that the
that it was originally set up in
administrative rules um which goes which
goes through the jail car public process
which is directed by statute okay so
you're saying that that that the stat
that that
statutes contemplate that there will be
some change made by other than a full
vote of the legislature
precisely and i believe i i can't speak
to the rationale but i believe that's
why an hb2 provision was put in this
past session so that there was greater
oversight and transparency to that
are there any further questions
i do have a couple i guess
i know that
snap benefits
affect other areas
so by increasing the percentage
what other programs
are going to be affected
by this change in the snap
criteria
there are no other eligibility programs
that are really certainly not adversely
impacted by this particular change
information that i had provided
in an answer to that it certainly does
make
more individuals eligible automatically
for head start who have children of that
age qualifying
there are also education and training
benefits that people will qualify for
because of receiving snap benefits
including job search and the ability to
pursue credentials that would result in
a higher paying job or a high demand job
they would also qualify for the free and
reduced meals through the school
and
with an agreement that we are putting
together with the cap agencies
these are individuals with their
permission would be contacted by those
cap agencies regarding lie he benefits
that they would qualify for
they also qualify for the what's known
as the double up food bucks program
which is a an incentive for purchasing
you probably don't know
whether or not these children
are currently eligible for free and
reduced lunch
or is the answer to that i don't
i i'm talking about you know the the
difference
um so they would they would so if you're
185 of federal poverty level below you'd
qualify for free if you're 250 percent
or below you would qualify for reduced
price lunch so between 200 and 185 is
that the question
yeah
it may be difficult for us so right now
we direct cert snap students so given
this change in eligibility criteria we
may have to do some additional work to
be able to parse the students between
free and reduced but we can work on that
okay so
because it's yet another tier yeah
yeah i got it
i got it
we'll know that before the budget cycle
right
so that
the only thing that would truly affect
the um
the state budget
is the free and reduced lunch
eligibility
yes
potentially
okay
and and then lie he
sure
certainly
i mean we would probably need to look
further at it but depending upon
how this change in classification is
recognized like human health and human
services at the federal level may
recognize it for one thing some of that
same information is used by the u.s
department of education
to determine specific funding levels
relative to
some of our title programs so i'm not
sure how u.s department of education
would recognize these shifts these
changes in terms of their funding
allocation formulas on the education
side
well
yeah
i think we better have somebody come
back and
talk to us in
november about that i think
because
we just we just need to know
you know what what's happening
just if it's helpful i can tell you that
there are a number of other states maybe
20 is my guess
including massachusetts that have moved
from the 185 percent federal property
level to 200 already so the the on the
federal level that may have been
resolved
well we'll see
anyhow
we'll look at
i don't think i have anything
particular scheduled for november but i
do think we need to
get a clear understanding of the
impact
that it's going to have on the on the
budget
uh representative earth
so
these are all federal funds correct
and we're raising the eligibility rate
here
you just said massachusetts or some
other states have it to 200 percent
that's can we set it a ten thousand
percent
um
that's an interesting question
uh representative i don't know that
there's a cap on the percentage but
i would anticipate that
um
with a need to be reasonable for the
purposes of snap
um
to you know address poverty
you know within the the percentage that
we're looking at
and not what you're suggesting
well
you just suggested it up to 200 in some
states
what's what percentage are we looking at
500 percent a thousand percent
i don't know that anyone is looking at
that
and chris sentinelo just indicated to me
we um we can go back and confirm this
but it's our understanding that 300 is
okay but yes i'm sure i remove the table
i have a motion
a table
seconded by um
americo chess
representative earth yes
represent leishman no
representative petrie yesterday
senator daniels yes
senator bradley
senator gray no
senator rosenwald no
senator perkins woke up no
madam chair the vote is
four yes six no
the uh
tabling motion
fails
did
did you want to make a different motion
move to a proof okay thank you
do i have a second
okay
this is a motion to approve
fis-280
representative henry votes yes
representative earth now
represent leicester yes
president petry
yes
senator daniels no
thunder bradley
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes
perkins cuoco yes
represent umberger yes
i'm sure the vote is eight to two in
affirmative
the vote being eight to two fis
22 280 passes
and that's with the understanding that
we will see you in november
for all things
education and snap how's that
because it will have uh some impact on
the budget
okay
we now move to
um
and
oh here it is
yeah i found it okay
um
the uh
representative leishman had a question
on
fis-22298
this is the
thank you madam chair
so i apologize for jumping uh earlier
but uh
we're finally at the right spot
so on
the table you provided us table eight
it had the annual totals for clients
served by community mental health
centers
and i see there's been quite a reduction
from 2012 to present i don't know if you
could explain why there's been a
reduction in service
so good afternoon
members of the committee and madam chair
i'm katya foxx i'm the director of the
division for behavioral health
and um first and foremost i want to say
that these statistics have been an area
that we've wanted to focus on
from where we pull the information and
so you'll be seeing
when we present an updated dashboard and
a new design of the dashboard we're also
going to change the way that we pull
these statistics
we want to
accurately reflect all of the work
that's being done by our community
mental health centers
and we believe that the new and improved
dashboard will also include new improved
data in this particular area with that
being said i think that
what i would like to focus on i see the
big drop that you probably noticed from
last month from june to july i went back
and looked at that and we also had an
even more significant drop last year
and a couple other years as you go
through the dashboard so we can
attribute it to several things probably
seasonality
with school ending and
the summer providing more opportunity to
not be
engaged in services
as people do
different things through the summer
months but also we know as you've
already heard about staffing issues
and the centers have been among the many
health care providers who've struggled
with staff and so you need staff to be
able to provide those services
all right thanks
thanks madam chair
are there any further questions yes
senator grossman thank you
um
two questions if i could i've we've seen
put money into
more restrictive settings in the mental
health system but not in
to the community mental health centers
to the same extent and i'm just
wondering if you could talk about why
we haven't worked to address the
staffing issue
financially
as we have
in facilities
so i'm just looking to see if someone
else wants to jump in but
first and foremost the community mental
health system through the 10-year plan
has been an amazing effort
that has occurred over the last few
years and i know you've been part of
that through legislative action to
provide significant funding that funding
has all gone to the community system so
we've been talking about housing we have
raised rates
through that process through medicaid
we've you know had the 3.1 percent
increase on a subsequent one we
supported the community mental health
centers through
the
arpa funding and before that the cares
act funding that has all gone to support
and shore up the community mental health
system and specifically to
community-based services we have housing
dollars that we've been
putting in there we have had different
initiatives and be happy to list those
out as a matter of fact you'll be
hearing about this next friday at health
and human i'm sorry with hhs oversight
because we are submitting our required
report um and then doing a presentation
on that on all of the efforts
so
we have been doing that and i don't
think there's any one sector in the
health care
system right now that has a solution and
has been able to
crack that nut when it comes to staffing
thank you my second question is probably
really for nathan
um
we got information that the department
had lapsed
35 million dollars
in revenues i think that's the
additional
6.2
um i i would have to dig into the
details to to specifically answer that
question um upon initial analysis i i
didn't identify
that um however i i know before
before i started in my role i know that
uh karen had previously spoke to all of
you about the revenue
um challenges that we have in
identifying and estimating those on an
ongoing basis
i do have an update on that we did
acquire a system we procured a system
this past spring and we developed it and
it is now currently live
the downside is that we're currently
entering data in for this upcoming
budget
but we won't we won't be able to really
utilize that until
uh until we have a full year of complete
data which would not be until the end of
state fiscal year 2024 which would allow
us the analytical tools to really easily
dig into that
i can go back and conduct a more
thorough analysis if you'd like
so that i can give you a little bit more
insight into
what um what revenue sources feed into
that that that revenue lapse if if you'd
like that would be great because sure
we've been told in the past it is the
additional federal match
but that means that we are not spending
the appropriation
and that's why we're
collapsing the funds so my question was
could the department tell us please
which programs
are
lapsing
appropriation that
is losing us federal revenues because we
can't find the services or something
sure can we find out where yes i'll i'll
go back and conduct that analysis and
follow that would be great thank you
thank you madam chair uh
since we're going to have education and
hhs here in november
is that soon enough or
i expect to be out of town for that
meeting but oh yes whatever obviously
whenever you schedule it well but
they'll be written materials i can look
at yeah but i would prefer you to be
here
sept
october
we have um
des coming to talk to us about pfas in
uh
landfills
and
it's exciting yeah it is
it's it's very exciting especially if
you uh if you looked at
what's going on with
with our landfills in the state so
um
i guess
they told me it would take them about
15-20 minutes
on the on october yeah in october
so
let's try to
do this in october
is that that would be amazing thank you
would that be okay
nathan oh i think so
i should
refer to you by your position i
apologize
okay so
hopefully we can we can get that
together
are there any further questions
okay are the
okay
and then we are anxiously awaiting a
presentation from uh
my name is jean mitchell i'm the audit
supervisor with the
lba audit division with me is the
adjutant general
nicholitis
so i'm here today to present the report
on our assessment of the internal
controls in place over the receipt
deposit recording and reporting of
revenue as well as the authorization
payment recording and reporting of the
department of military affairs and
veterans services
expenditures during the nine months
ended march 31st
if you turn to the table of contents you
will see the executive summary
summary of results background our audit
objectives scope methodology are located
on pages one through five of the report
the report contains three findings and
recommendations none of which suggest
legislative action may be required
the department concurred with all of the
observations
moving on to the background section on
page two
the department was legislative create
legislatively created by senate bill 208
which became effective in september of
the bill consolidated military and
veterans services which were previously
housed in three separate departments
into the department of military affairs
and veterans services the department is
organized into divisions including the
division of veterans services the
division of community-based military
programs and the state's veterans
cemetery
as well as two advisory boards the
veterans council and the military
leadership team
the department is overseen by the
adjutant general
who essentially functions as the
commissioner and is also a member of the
national guard
the department is funded mainly by
federal revenue reimbursements
the department
spends funds in accordance with the
master cooperative agreement which
provides federal support for services
provided to state military departments
for authorized facilities for leases
real property services operations
maintenance repair and minor
construction costs
as well as several several military
construction cooperative agreements
which provides federal support for the
construction of military facilities real
property improvements and design
services
the department records its revenue and
expenditures in the general fund in the
capital projects fund across 61
different accounting units within the
state accounting system
on page four you will see a summary of
the department's revenues and
expenditure activity for the nine months
ended march 31st
which includes approximately 11 million
dollars in total revenues and 22 million
dollars in total
expenditures we conducted our audit in
accordance with government auditing
standards the objective of the audit was
to evaluate whether the state had
designed communicated implemented and
operated suitable internal controls over
the receipt deposit recording and
reporting of the department's web
revenue as well as the authorization
payment recording and reporting of the
department's expenditures
as reported in the summary of the
results we found the department's
controls over the receipt deposit
recording of their revenues as well as
the authorization payment recording
reporting of their expenditures were
generally suitably designed to provide
reasonable assurance that the specified
internal control objections were were
achieved
the observations begin on page seven
in observation number one
recommend that the department formally
document its policies and procedures
covering the major areas of its
financial operations and to look for
areas to gain efficiencies within its
current process for tracking and
requesting federal reimbursements of
expenditures
written policies and procedures should
be approved by management and it be in
sufficient detail to prevent significant
disruption in its operations
upon the departure or absence of key
employees
in observation number two beginning on
page nine we recommend the department
establish and document a formal risk
assessment process for recognizing
evaluating and responding to risk that
could affect the major areas of its
financial operations including the
receipt deposit and recording of revenue
and the authorization payment recording
and reporting of its expenditures
the risk assessment should be
periodically reviewed and revised as
necessary to ensure it remains relevant
and should be reviewed
and formally documented
finally observation number three on page
10 recommends the department work with
the state department of administrative
services in the national guard bureau to
document its arrangement with the new
hampshire national guard for the federal
supervision of state employees in a
memorandum of understanding or other
formal policy document
which evidences the agreement of both
parties
the policy document should clearly
outline the roles and responsibilities
of each party to ensure the supervision
of department employees and approval of
employee time cards is completed in
accordance with state policy
we also recommend the department
current process for completing a
secondary review of employee time cards
should be strengthened to include the
evidence of the review
additionally the department should
consider requiring new hampshire
national guard supervisors who receive
access to the state's time management
system to complete a confidentiality
agreement underscoring that they may
have access to personal and confidential
information and that they are not to
disseminate it
the appendix beginning on page 13
reports the current status of prior
audit findings
the status key on the bottom of page 14
reports the department has fully
resolved seven observations and one
remains unresolved
this concludes my presentation and we
would like to thank the adjutant general
the deputy adjutant in general as well
as the business office staff for their
help and cooperation during the audit
process
and if we you had any questions we could
this is a question dealing with
does the guard bureau the dc guard
bureau
have people located in your office
uh ma'am for the record uh uh major
general david mikulita sergeant general
department of military affairs rented
services no
you're selling dc guard like the
washington dc district of columbia
national guard are you talking like no
i'm talking about the bureau
the national guard bureau uh
yes one it's we call them the united
property and fiscal officer so he's a
title 10 individual who's essentially
our federal money guy
so his money's dispersed through
national guard bureau to the state of
new hampshire it goes through him so
he's sort of our federal money guy then
he dirt disperses the funds for the
state business office well who is he
paid by
uh the usr well he's air force uh the
u.s air force so he's paid by the guard
bureau
yes okay the okay
uh beca because it was confusing to me
this write-up dealing with uh who could
sign time cards you know
and uh who could you know supervise
because
anyhow normally it's the ranking person
no matter who they are
right right so in this particular case
just conceptually 3000 strong about 2800
service members about
fifty federal title five civilians and
150 state employees
most of the state employees work
underneath maintenance maintaining our
facilities throughout the state both
army and air so generally speaking that
maintenance worker his supervisor is
probably either a federal civilian or a
federal military individual
so he that individual is the one who
signs the time card
because they're the ones who have
oversight so it's just more of the
documentation of
the risk associated with um that time
card
signing process
does that help
okay i just want to make sure that we're
not uh
creating complications that don't need
we do it it's just not a formalized
process
so we have no issue with the finding
okay so you'll
you'll set up a procedure or something
or other for that yes okay yes ma'am all
right thank you
i do have one
more sorry
i know that um risk assessment is a
problem across
all agencies
not just
whatever you are now
military affairs um
and
i'm not exactly sure
how we solve this problem
whether it's a
reminder to all the commissioners or
or a
new audit that just goes out and looks
at
do you have risk assessments
because this comes up all the time
and um
i
i recognize
that in my past life i got dinged
because i didn't have risk assessments
and um
and i mean we are dealing with
public money
and we should be
guarding those dollars accurately
and we're following the procedure so and
since this was written up
in your in
and it
was still open and now we are in some
other year
and i i just get concerned that
you know risk assessment
is
probably not on the
front burner of and i'm not i'm not
talking just about military affairs but
i'm talking about the entire
scope of the state government so
anyhow that's just my
my comment and i know that uh mr kane
will
take that back so
okay is there anything else that you
would
like to to say
either one
uh ma'am this day was uh exceptional we
get we have an internal auditing
department on the federal side so we get
audited a ton uh to make sure the
disbursement of federal funds for the
state is in an appropriate manner um it
was exceptional working with them and uh
we have no other comments other than
stockholm senator daniels earlier is um
just struggling when you hear all these
other state departments talk about the
challenge for either healthcare workers
uh snowplow drivers um no one's joining
the military this year
um in the army we're having our worst
recruiting year since the end of the
draft in 1972 and it's affecting us
that's that's true
very true across
not only the guard and the reserves but
the active duty as well i uh
i read that and it makes me sad
okay thank you very much uh appreciate
it and thank you for your work
and now mr arlinghaus
oh wait i need a motion on the uh
adam chair i move to accept place on
file and release the to the public in
the usual manner this audit second
okay
thank you
you got those two people
yourself and representative petry
uh
can the clerk call the roll or do i need
to mr
i can just do a show of hands
can i just do a show of hands okay
hello all those in favor
opposed
all right the motion passes
thank you very much
so
by the way very good
yeah
so it is a very good piece of paper and
i didn't do it joyce did
um
i'm charlie erlinghouse i'm the
commissioner of administrative services
i am joyce pittman the director of risk
and benefits
um uh chair umberger asked us to do a
presentation
and uh to talk to you about how we how
we pay for health insurance for state
employees and retirees and it's very
easy when for us to get in our heads and
think everybody
everybody remembers when the state went
from self-insured to from fully insured
to self-insured
when craig benson was governor god knows
how many of you were in office at the
time um and then although actually
probably more of you than
not
um but
a refresher is always good because we
live and breathe this every day and
i wish senator perkins quokka was still
here because i wanted to say that one of
the most important things in recruiting
employees in the state
wages are
wages are always the first thing right
we're all crazy if we don't pretend we
don't look at the salary but for the
state one of the ways we're wonderfully
competitive is on health benefits um and
it's because we do a really good job on
health benefits and are able therefore
to offer good health benefits and that's
largely because of people like joyce
who's going to talk to you
okay
thank you
thank you madam chair for the
opportunity to come here and talk about
the health benefit plan
i know it's late for
this presentation in the morning or
actually early afternoon so i do want to
have it interactive so if there's
something i'm going over too quickly
please stop me if that's okay
but the division of risk and benefits
submits an informational item
every other month to the fiscal
committee and the purpose of this
presentation is just as charlie said is
to provide some of that background
but um before we get too deep into the
slides i'm on slide three i thought it
would be helpful to talk about the two
different types of health benefit plans
and the funding mechanisms for those
benefit plans
that we we use them frequently in our
world but not sure if everybody knows
what we're referring to
so there are two different funding
mechanisms for health benefit plans
that we focus on one of them is fully
insured and basically with a fully
insured plan you're looking at who's
assuming the risk
for the the cost of the claims in a
fully insured claim it's usually a an
insurance carrier who we pay a premium
to
every monthly
a monthly basis per our members per
month and then they assume the claim
cost in exchange for that they may
receive some sort of federal funding
i'll speak in particular to our medicare
advantage program our medicare advantage
program for our retirees is fully
insured
which means aetna who's our current
carrier pays those claims all those
health care claims that our retiree
receives and in exchange for that we pay
them a premium which i'm going to talk
about in a little bit
and then the other type of plan is a
self-funded plan and that's where the
state is on the hook for the cost of
those health benefits those claims
expenses
um
so
in exchange for paying for those claims
we are also eligible to receive
subsidies when we're talking about
prescription drugs we talk about rebates
regularly so those rebates come back to
the state
if it's a medicare
well we have a medicare
part d plan for prescription drugs for
our medicare retirees
we pay for those prescription drugs and
we get federal subsidies to do so and
i'll talk more about that
to come
uh just a quick question sure uh are all
state employees
under the self-funded program
state employees are yes okay so
every across the board yes okay and then
the
retirees are under the fully insured so
on slide four
you're giving me a great segue to get to
the next slide
the retirees are split so what you'll
see at the top from our
employer-sponsored group health plans
the active employees and our troopers
they are for their medical benefits
through anthem that is self-funded
as well as the prescription drugs
through express scripts also self-funded
and then all the way to the right you'll
see that we have northeast delta dental
which is also self-funded
and so across the top are all of our
active employees and anybody who's
eligible to participate on our active
employee plan
then below that you see the retiree
health plan and that's really split
so our non-medicare retirees we often
use the phrase commercial it's our
commercial plan with our actives and our
non-medicare retirees
they are self-funded and they're on the
an anthem self-funded plan as well as
express scripts as a self-funded plan
i just want to jump in
um
self-funded
they are not self-funded we
we are the self not they are the self
so i just and i know everybody knows
that but i want to remind you
self-funded means the state's on the
hook
as opposed to the insurance companies on
the hook it does not mean the person is
on the hook
i know
every now and again yeah thank you
so then at the bottom there you'll see
medicare and medicare we actually have
that population and they fully insured
aetna's on the hook to use that phrase
to pay those medical claims
that is a medicare advantage program
also referred to as a medicare part c
plan
and then our medicare
part d prescription drug d as in dog
plan is self-funded through express
scripts
um
the laws establishing our health benefit
plan are the laws that manage us under
21i30 it says the state shall pay a
premium partial premium toward group
health benefits or self-funded
alternative which we've just discussed
within the limits of the funds
appropriated each legislative session
and then more specifically section e of
21i30
specifies that we will have an employee
and retiree risk
management fund we refer to it as fund
60 and that is an internal service fund
that is non-lapsing and continually
appropriated to dis and we're using
those funds only for the use of the
health benefit plan to pay for those
claims and administrative fees that are
yeah oh yes senator daniels thank you
before we leave uh page four
uh just a quick question on the
non-medicare self-funded with anthem is
that the same plan as the act of
employees and troopers have
it it's actually
it's very similar they have a little bit
of a different copay structure but yes
it's the same they're still using the
national preferred formulary okay that
the active employees have
and on your on your medicare
is there a reason
why you are using a medicare c
program without drugs versus
getting one with and then a standalone
program
the reason now is really a resort a
result of contracting so our
prescription drug contract is under a
different program but we always explore
what would that look like
if we were to pull
pharmacy into our medicare part c
program so that would be a medicare
advantage plan
with a mapd medicare advantage plan
prescription drug plan
but at this time just based on how we've
contracted it
we actually implemented medicare
advantage in 2000 it was 2018 for plan
year one one of 19.
and then 19 and 20 was through anthem
and then we transitioned with ex
with
aetna for the medicare advantage plan
for 2020
and we still had express scripts
separate but we always explore that as
an alternative so there's no reason it's
preventing us from doing it it's just
the way it is right now if we see that
we could um
attain additional savings
we will do that but we are still getting
federal subsidies under the
current it's called an employer group
waiver plan we refer to the acronym as
egwip
but i live in the world of acronyms so i
try not to use those too much but our
egg whip is a prescription drug it's a
part d plan so we are getting that
subsidy we're just holding on to it
instead of sending it over to our part c
provider okay and
final question medicare c plans change
every year are our contracts with
whoever is providing those
longer than one year
we are currently in a three-year
contract with aetna that started in
2020.
when we negotiated that contract with
aetna they came back with a zero premium
so the premium for
aetna to assume the risk for our
medicare eligible retirees to be on that
plan is costs in the state nothing per
month
so
we have that rate guarantee through 2023
and then we have to look at our plan
experience to see what our options are
for anything beyond that
good thank you
do you want to add anything
so
das
determines the rate and then they
identify or they charge the individual
agencies for the cost of their people
okay yes
and so we we
use the term working rate
to determine the total cost of what the
health care is going to cost on a per
member per month basis
we actually do that on a per employee
per month
and it's a term like and in healthcare
we use belly buttons when you're looking
at members like how many members are in
your household so each house could have
multiple people covered under the plan
multiple members
our plan is based on employee how many
employees per month
so
that working rate
inc it's a
all-inclusive charge that we charge out
so for our medicare retirees for example
even though the medical portion of that
working rate is zero there is still cost
for access to the prescription drug
benefit remember that's still
self-funded so the state is still paying
the cost of the prescription drug claims
right in exchange for those federal
subsidy dollars and rebates
but also um any kind of administrative
fees for like the division of risk and
benefits we have salaries included in
there we have a health benefits
consultant that we work with siegel that
helps us develop those working rates and
budget rates every year
there's a cost for them as well and
that's included in that working rate
and you'll see more information about
the cost of those working rates in a few
slides
so on slide six whoops
yeah i don't need that it's okay on
slide six it
i just thought it would be an
interesting question how much does the
state pay for health benefits seems like
a logical question to ask
um thank you so the total cost of the
employee and retiree health benefit plan
in fy 23
is approximately 320 million dollars of
which the 43 of that is generally funded
and then i break out just the
populations just so you can see for fy
by active and the trooper plan the
retiree health benefit plan cost and
then dental sometimes is forgotten but
that is included in our cost as well
and then our budget for the active
employee and trooper plan the budget is
sitting in the class class 60s
for the agencies and then the retiree
health benefit budget
there are self-funded agencies that
budget for their projected retirees as
well as das has
a retiree health budget
when you look at slide seven wait wait
when you say
self-funded agencies
what what agencies
oh do you know which agency so um yes
there's
the wire they so they're they're
bringing so why are they self-funded
they're non-generally funded agencies
that we bill for the retiree health
costs it's carried in their budget in
class 64. that money is then transferred
into
into risk and benefits in our budget and
you'll see that if you were in division
one you would see that in the retiree
health line
the generally funded agencies or
population is budgeted as a lump sum
general fund so the retiree health
budget in which shows up in house bill 1
in the in the das budget you'll see half
of it is transfers from agencies
via class 64
and half of it is not quite is general
funds and that's a lump sum
general fund appropriation
in that portion of our budget
those of you who have been on group
division one in the past will know that
i start my presentation with
a tale of two budgets we have two
budgets one is our our divisional
operating budget and the other is the
retiree health budget
which is a lot of money
yeah
just some examples of agencies that are
self-funded so we have liquor
transportation
safety
banking is in there insurance insurance
is in there yeah
that's fine i just
trying to when you say self-funded i'm
going
i don't know of any agency that doesn't
get something from the general fund
maybe lottery and liquor but
it's a
it's a function of uh right of their
employees and the the you know when this
is a de minimis thing 20 or 30 years ago
and it wasn't ever de minimis but um
it didn't matter but at some point you
know the the history of state budgeting
if you look for
probably forever but certainly for 20 or
30 years
is a question of how do we how do we
make sure that we're capturing costs and
the general fund and you if you think of
things like things like sweatcap for
example it's a it's a it's a way to get
the non-general fund
portions of the operation so to speak
to pay the
uh to pay their share of that function
as opposed to it all being just like oh
just stick that in a general fund and so
with retirees it's like well who you
know you retired from liquor therefore
you're this you retired from admin
services
um in one of our general funding pieces
on slide seven you'll see some uh
history of the total health benefit
this is it's it's kind of a logical
slide to look at where you can see that
costs are going up over the years you
can see a little bit of a blip between
fy19 and fy20
um
i'd like to say it's 100 because we went
to medicare advantage and saved all
kinds of money but there was something
else that happened in calendar year 2020
that definitely impacted the cost of
health care
so
we did see a decline in health care
expenditures in during the covid times
but you'll also see quickly after that
that we've rebound we've rebounded so
on slide eight we have an internal fund
60 management team that meets every we
we meet bi-monthly but we report to
monthly on what our fund balances are
and we use that as
a management tool for looking at fund
balances looking at where we're going
for our budget these are our working
rate budget rates
we also have reported to fiscal in the
not too
distant history about doing premium
holidays for certain populations and
it's how we're managing our reserves
just to make sure that we're giving that
money back if the reserves are getting
higher than thresholds that we've
determined
like basically covet covid was slowing
down cost expenditures so
we don't want to allow those reserves to
get too high
thank you madam chair and as one of
taking advantage of the retiree plan
i'd like to thank you for the holiday we
had this summer
for premiums
you're welcome there you go
so you know about holidays
excellent
we give the money back to where we got
it
it's a notion it's something worth
noting right is that um
we're collecting we're collecting
premiums we're collecting benefit
charges from agencies into an internal
service fund we're collecting money from
retirees
and we have a statutory responsibility
and a moral responsibility obviously but
to to not collect more than you're
supposed to
and if you collect more than you're
you collected it as a health charge you
can't then go out and spend it on a
christmas tree
and or something like that and and and
that's one of the reasons for the
holidays is for that reason that that
this is money we've we had this
discussion when senator d'allesandro
usually asked asked would ask about it
but um
we can't legitimately
and legally i think use that money for
any other purpose
like there would be no point where we
looked at it and went you know we need
to repave that why don't we just use
that because we got extra
we collected it as a as a as the
equivalent of a healthcare premium it
must be used for that and it's part of
the reason that there's a there's a
management
team on the internal service fund and
it's part of the reason that fiscal has
historically wanted us reporting to them
every two months is to say
yeah what'd you collect
did you use it
what are you doing about that and it's
and it's that i don't want to say
they're skeptical but it's basically you
know keep us informed about what's going
on because uh
rep representative emrick
do do you know what do you normally keep
as a i'll call it a reserve
for self for self funding because
obviously you know the state is paying
for that and you don't want to
run out of money there but if you get
extra in
what's your buffer this is one of my
favorite things um
it's i'm sort of obsessed about it
um
we have there's a there are two kinds of
reserve a statutory reserve and a and uh
um and a cash balance reserve but
they're both reserves so one is
specified in statute as a percentage
it's a slightly different percentage for
retirees for
the separate trooper group and for
actives but it's three percent or five
percent for for either one actually i
think for for troopers it's 100
in law it's three minimum of three it's
what we've chosen and then we've chosen
to set that because troopers are a very
small group that are very volatile
partly because they're small actives are
a very large group we have less
volatility one of the things we discuss
often at the internal
at the internal um governance meetings
is how big should the reserve be we have
targets which are currently set as a as
a shorthand at
at um two to three months of revenue
two i'm sorry two to three months of
expenditure how much do you want to have
in reserve a couple to three months of
expenditure
one of the things that that that i look
at in particular routinely is
what's your high month what you're low
month because months aren't aren't equal
i mean generally we spend on a weekly
basis rather than a monthly basis in
terms of billing and administration so
there's a four-week month and a
five-week month
but that the the delta between the
highest month over the last two years
and the lowest month over the last two
years the the ratio between them is more
than 100 percent that is you know
something like 250
612 000 and so what we want to guard
against is
we want to look at two things trend
um you know and trend isn't just this
month go up or down because there are
all kinds of reasons for that um but the
other thing is um
um
are we getting to the point where the
reserves are ticking down down down down
and so we need to look at what's going
on and be careful or up up up up in
which case we need to plan a holiday
reserves get too high we have a holiday
reserves get reserves get too low we
don't have holidays and we have to start
thinking about things the last time we
had a serious cash flow
threat
maybe it was 2015
and fiscal in in those years took action
on things like on the retiree side in
particular on things like um
premium payment prescription drug
payments and there was a lot of
discussion about what we might do and
then in 20 the 2017 past budget there
was a a change to the retiree health
eligibility
yes
so along those same lines on slide nine
we
hold a term or a expression that former
commissioner of das linda hodgston said
how do you know how much the question
was how do you know how much health how
much money you need to pay for your
health benefits and she said it's
basically like landing a 747 on the head
of a pin
and it's a result of all the different
variables that influence health care
expenditures and the next slide on slide
10 just goes over a few of those there
are more than this but one of the key
variables that we look at is enrollment
enrollment going up
um is it
also the cost trends around that what
are people spending their money on you
can't predict who's going to get what
diagnoses and who's going to need what
for for care but you try to look at that
over what you've been trending
as well as claim mix inflation
innovation there are drugs out there now
that cost a lot of money
but they're saving lives
so we want that to be available for our
members we rely on our third party
administrators to help us manage those
costs but there is that potential for
those those types of expenses coming to
the plan in addition to as you all know
the the funding the the sources of those
funds in the budget
and also plan design looking at how our
members are utilizing the plan what are
they paying for that cost share um there
is some change when you when you
increase deductibles people start to
weigh in that consumerism is introduced
um and that's that's with everybody
um and then at the bottom of page 10
there's the on the right there's that
bullet that says
different incentives getting our members
engaged in shopping for health care and
looking for they're all high quality
health care but the price variation
amongst providers can be significant so
can we incent their behavior to shop
give them a little incentive and save
the plan some money
and that is something that we can do for
only our active and our non-uh medicare
so we do provide some incentive or we
don't
we do for our active employees there's a
program called smart shopper
and if they shop first before they seek
services and they actually go to one of
those high quality lower cost providers
they can receive a cash back incentive
for doing that
and the same for our non-medicare
medicare does not allow any kind of
steerage right and that's considered
steerage so we're not permitted to do
something like that for our medicare
population okay
thank you
um so on slide 11
the members enrolled in our health
benefit plan if you're
talking about belly buttons as i
mentioned earlier we're looking at about
37 500 members on our health benefit
plan
and it's broken out by the actives we
have about 23 000
troopers 850
excuse me 850 and then our retiree plan
is split like we've been talking about
so about 13 500
2500 non-medicare and about 11 000
medicare retirees the big difference
between our active plan whether in our
troopers plan is their plan design and
everything about their health benefits
is collectively bargained
on the retiree plan side their benefits
are determined by the legislature
and and so there's that's a big
difference between those two different
programs
are the other state employees is that
part of the collective bargaining or
do you just
the state employees yeah so the state
employees are you talking about all
state employees i'm talking about the
2300 members so the 2300 that's the
members they're about 93
100 state employees and yes they're all
somehow connected to the collectively
bargained planned design okay i can't
it's okay it's a lot of information to
on slide 12 i just did a deeper dive on
retiree enrollment mainly because
um
as charlie just said we've made changes
over the past few years to how our
retiree health benefits are designed to
work on cost containment strategies but
one thing we can't prevent is people
getting older
so that is happening and what you'll see
on slide 12
not no no so the top line that you can
see going up that's our medicare
population and you can see
from 2013 to 2000 our projected 2025
population were over 11 000 members
there and then the bottom line
is the non-medicare population and so
one reason why that population is
declining is because they're getting
older and they're moving on to the
medicare plan
and the other reason is that we made
some changes to our eligibility for the
people who are eligible to retire before
age 65 before they're medicare eligible
so that's also part of it the other part
of it is people are working longer
so they're not retiring before they're
medicare eligible they're actually in
the workforce longer so there's a few
competing demands that are it's pushing
that medicare enrollment faster than and
you'll see that decline on the
non-medicare
so
i pay money
every month for my
medicaid
medicare
where does that go
in for the medic
medicaid retiree medicare are you uh are
you a state retiree
no
so you're probably are you thinking
about your medicare part b premium that
you're paying that's coming out so
that's going that's going through
actually i think it's coming out of your
social security check
so the the federal government is taking
that
that's not coming to us we're not
getting what you're paying out of your
social security check is not coming no
but i'm talking about the retirees
the medicare retirees so our medicare
retirees are also paying a medicare part
b premium and it's the same thing so
we're not collecting okay so that goes
to the federal government yes it does
and then that must be part of the
federal reimbursement
so our
medicare eligible retirees are paying
they're paying two things they're paying
a
medicare part b
premium that's coming out of their
social security check and that's going
that way and they're also paying a
premium that's coming to us that gives
us gives them access to our group health
benefits
that's the and you'll actually see that
in a few slides of what they're paying
but it's roughly about twenty dollars
per member per month that they're paying
that's coming to us
in exchange for that 20
the cost of health care so our medicare
retirees are responsible to pay a
medicare part b deductible
and that's this year it's like 203
dollars so once they've met that out of
pocket they're getting
their coverage through the medicare part
c program let's leave pharmacy aside for
a moment they're getting their medical
benefits through the aetna plan aetna
then
is the one who's submitting the bill to
the federal government that's it so our
retirees go to the doctor they give
their medicare advantage etna card to
their doctor
and the doctor in exchange invoices or
bills aetna and then aetna handles okay
this is a part a or part b you know a is
your hospital-based charges or your
inpatient charges and part b is your
outpatient type of services aetna
handles all of that
so in this world medicare part a plus
medicare part b equals medicare part c
if that makes sense and aetna takes care
of that for our members
on the medicare part d
as you know as in dog drug
they
are our members use their
express scripts
id card when they go to the pharmacy
and then
express scripts turns around and they
actually invoice us for the cost of that
drug and we pay for that but in exchange
our retirees pay a co-pay and that
depends on whether or not it's a generic
a preferred or non-preferred i included
some more of that information if you
really want to dig deeper in the
appendix
i just didn't want to get that granular
because i know
it can get really weedy but there is an
appendix that gets a little bit into
like what's the co-pay structure and
whatnot
did that answer your question
okay perfect
on slide 13
just more about how we're trying to
maximize our federal funding so in 2015
we moved to that employer group waiver
program that i was referring to as an
egg whip plan for our prescription drug
prior to that we had a program called
rds which stands for retiree drug
subsidy so the state was still receiving
subsidies from the federal government
but through working with siegel we were
able to determine that we could increase
our federal subsidy by moving to that
employer group waiver program
through express scripts so we made that
change in 2015 and have increased that
that revenue source to our plan
um in 2019 i know i already covered this
just to recap really quick
we actually did an amendment to our
anthem medical tpa contract to carve out
our medicare population and put them
into the fully insured
anthem program
in 2019
and the premium that they were
paying just for that anthem program was
about 109 11 per month
i say about and i am giving you down to
the penny
it's burned in my brain
and then that was the same for 2020 but
then we went out to bid
procurement as you know is a strategy to
look for
cost saving strategies and cost
containment strategies in 2021 that's
when we were able to
lock down that zero per member per month
premium
for aetnas
access to the adna program and that like
i said is a three-year contract and
we're estimating about 15 million
dollars in savings per year for 2020 21
also we're looking at improvements we
have we have a question i thought i just
heard you say that that the retirees
were paying
20 a month
so remember so the retiree that's the
working rate and i'll show you that too
so you'll see those numbers break out
but that's the total cost of their
premium which includes pharmacy
okay so actually what they're doing is
they're
the the zero
per person per month you're talking
about is actually
no deductible on health care
or no premium on health care but twenty
dollars
but okay but the other one is
self-funded
so the 20 that they're paying
is a so it's it's um like 200 a month is
what the state pays to provide our
retirees
the um
access to those group health benefits so
the aetna
the express scripts
and then that extra administrative cost
for consulting and dis salary you know
risk and benefits salaries and that sort
of thing that's that's less than
less than three percent that that's a
small amount so
you'll see that coming up on a slide so
you can see the breakdown so we
calculate that 10 percent which is in
law so if you're a medicare retiree and
your date of birth is on
or after 1 1 of 1949
you pay a 10
premium
and that's 10 of the working rate which
is roughly 200 so that's where they're
paying the 20.
and you'll see that again
in a little
bit um just the other thing like i said
before is we look at procurement as a
mechanism to save to find more ways of
saving money for the state
um we had a contract we have a contract
with anthem through 2022
and we just renewed with express scripts
and we're able to attain about a five
percent savings for the state just by
doing that procurement
that's good
yes please
the when you said that the costs to the
state i think you said for the aetna was
like 200 a month
and that's where the 20
that the
that the employee pays
is that did i understand that correctly
i mean roughly that that's correct
so let's skip to slide 16 because i
think if you can see the numbers it it
so over the years um
you can it should say at the top
medicare monthly premium contribution
history
and if you look at the bottom there as
of 1 1 of 2022 you see 204.87
that's what we call our total working
rate that's what per
member so each retiree on medicare and
or their spouse because the spouses are
also can be on medicare
they that's what it costs us per member
to be on our plan for both
scripture for the total working rate
includes both aetna which remembers zero
and express scripts which is roughly
about twenty dollars
or two hundred and four dollars excuse
me that which also includes the das
administrative
small margin to add to that right so you
know my mic no i i i guess i understand
that i guess my my question just to make
sure i'm understanding so
that strikes me as a really
the 204 87
strikes me as a really small amount of
money
which which leads me to believe that
most of the most of
most of how aetna is being compensated
for
for for being the insurer is they're
getting paid by the feds from our
medicare premiums which are a lot more
than twenty dollars a month so they're
they're also getting paid by the fed so
when you look at a medicare advantage
program they're getting paid by
the federal government to keep that care
at a certain level
so they're they're managing their care
and then they get what is referred to as
um
well they get a risk score so the the
if they're managing their population
they get a rate by how i'm going to say
how sick their population is and it
increases the amount of money the
federal government pays them
but they also if they can keep those
people healthier they keep that money so
by them inheriting our population that
roughly what did i say like 11 000
people and they can manage that in their
bigger book of business because that is
big
so it's not just us but they also got a
lion's share of a large population in
the state of new hampshire so if you're
coming into a market and you want to
start taking over a business in new
hampshire as a medicare advantage
program if you can take on the state as
your client
it's worth the zero premium that they're
charging us so we're leveraging that
yeah but the big picture they get money
from the state only in this case they
don't and they get money from the feds
and the and they got to cover their
costs with those and edna just said yeah
we can make enough off the feds so we're
good
and and by the way they probably thought
that at zero they would win the bid
and they were right
so basically this is this is the cost of
the supplemental insurance
for retirees on medicare
um i i don't like to use that word
because that's a different thing no but
in in a dumb person's conceptualization
there's a gap between what medicare pays
and what i have to pay
and this is basically covering that
this is basically paying for your i'll
say it this way your prescription drug
benefit i feel better if you walk away
with that than saying it's paying for a
supplemental plan because there is
something called a medicare supplemental
plan and we no longer have that we used
to but we don't have that anymore i i
fine i don't want to get up in the words
i know senator daniels knows exactly
what i mean i clarify that with a
medicare advantage plan medicare does
not pay any of the claims
they give a subsidy to private companies
like aetna humana anthem
places like that so your insurance is
through a private
private company which as she pointed out
is is different than a supplement which
medicare pays say 80 percent of it and
then a supplement picks up the other 20
so it's a whole new structure but you do
have to pay that uh part b premium of
200 uh 233 dollars in order to be
eligible
to get a medicare advantage plan
thank you
he does this
i know
so i'm just going to go back we just
quickly glazed over um i think we're
done this slide 13 at the bottom there
just says we made some changes to plan
design and then slide 14 i'm often asked
this of like what did we do on the
eligibility side of how do you get into
retiree health benefits and you can see
it's on slide 14 it's divided by group
one and group two
um and then you can see the changes that
were made so prior to july
1st of 2003
um
there was a different benefit but as of
that day we required 10 years of service
and a minimum age of 60 unless you had
over 30 years of service and then you
can see the next change that was made
and these changes are being made in law
um on or after july 1 of 2003 but before
july 1 of 11
the service requirement increased to 20
years i'm looking at the group one
box on the top and it's still the same
minimum age requirement
and then as you can see on or after july
1 of 2011 it's still 20 years but that's
the we changed the entry point to being
age 65 and that's where you're seeing
that decline on the non-medicare side
because people are on that
eligibility for medicare side of the
coin
and it's similar to group two i won't
read that unless you would like me to go
and then on slide 15 you can see the
changes
that we've made in the non-medicare
premium over the years so starting in
july of 2009 that's when our retirees
started paying a premium it was a flat
dollar sixty five dollar per month
fee to be on our non-medicare retiree
health plan
and then as the years went on um you can
see in january of 2016 we actually um
fiscal committee actually increased the
premium contribution
from 12.5
to 17.5
and then prior to then after that um in
october of 2017 i want to say charlie
that was the trailer bill the big
christmas tree bill included in that
bill was the
increase from 17 and a half percent to
and that's where we still are today for
i know we covered slide 16 but you can
see so as of january 1 of 2018 this was
actually included in that same
bill that increased us to 20 for the
non-medicare
um for medicare you have to make changes
on a calendar year basis if it's a i'm
going to call it a negative change or a
change that cost the retirees more on
medicare so we had to postpone that
change to january 1 of 2018
so if you were a retiree and or your
spouse with a date of birth on or after
1 1 of 1949
you're that's when we started having a
charge to our retirees on medicare of 10
and you can see through cost containment
efforts that in 18 it started at
36.24 cents per month
and then you can see we were able to
decrease that in 19 that's when we went
remember to medicare advantage
we kept it flat in 20
in 21 it decreased again that's a result
of the change changeover with the zero
premium going to aetna in 2021 so our
retirees paid 10 almost 10 dollars less
per month
at that point and then here we are in
january of 2022
i
i just have to add because
this is insane
i'm going to just point this out this is
ridiculous in terms of what happened
it's not literally not possible i'd have
told you
uh costs are not going to go down from
362. our goal is to make them go up
slowly from 362. and they went down to
and and if you had showed me this after
the fact and i hadn't lived through it i
would tell you that somebody made it
made an arithmetic error and was adding
it up wrong and that that you know a lot
of this is joyce and just to be honest
i'm joyce and cassie keane or most of
the committee knows and a lot of work
over a lot of time but
we our goal is to hit singles that's
what we it's what we try to do every day
and and they hit like four grand slams
in a row and it's not going to keep
happening because we're running out of
rep there are only so many rabbits you
can fit in a hat
and she's pulled them all out i think
but
it's worth noting that you know our
trend looks
like remarkable where you know
healthcare and the rest of the country
is going up 10 a year and we've gone
down and we've cut it almost in half and
you know we're done
and but
it's it's something that i highlight the
slide because i'm really really really
proud of it
it's not me
it's her and her team but i'm really
proud of it and it and it's something
that nobody in this committee you know
named me the last program you had where
somebody came in and went you know what
i think we can give you a better benefit
next year for half the price
and that doesn't happen and it's not
supposed to happen and it and it did so
anyway that's me giving her a pen on the
back
thank you
on the last slide on uh almost last
night slide 17
this was a question that i was regularly
asked to report back to fiscal law on
we're charging a medicare population and
it's only that date of birth that the
line in the sand that we had to draw
and the theory behind that and we work
closely with the legislature to come up
with that date it was not a randomly
grabbed out of the hat kind of date to
keep with the rabbit analogy
but but it was very um
how much could we get away with yeah or
so how can we charge the least amount of
people possible but in time you can see
from fiscal 18
to
to our projections for
fy25 you can see that our medicare
retirees are projected to continue to
increase
but you can also see just through
time alone that the people not paying
is decreasing
and the people paying
is increasing
so without moving the date of birth just
over time it's more people are paying
that's what that is meant to illustrate
i used to always call this the ober
and then this is the last slide before
the um
appendix is just what we keep doing
we're going to keep doing what we've
been doing so we're going to keep
managing our vendors we're going to keep
looking for cost containment strategies
we're going to keep going out to bid
we're going to keep looking for more
competitive pricing
more creative funding rate arrangements
trying to get
increased federal subsidies where it's
possible we are going to keep exploring
what what does it mean with our
prescription drug when do you flip it
like those are things we ask every year
and we we try to develop future
strategies to do that
we also work with our retirees and our
active employees on how they're managing
their individual health because if we
can curb that utilization and keep those
preventive visits on the rise get those
diagnoses if needed earlier manage their
health care manage the diabetes that's
saving us money
and then of course plan design those
sorts of things looking at ways to
incent
cost-effective health care so we're
going to keep doing that and analyzing
the data and hopefully as charlie says
there may be a small rabbit in there
somewhere i just don't know i'm not
there's actually a little bunny in there
yes you may
it's interesting that the medicare
system is working against you
because they require
certain levels of care you have to have
every six months you know my wife's a
diabetic so she has to go see an
endocrinologist every six months and if
she doesn't he the prescriptions can't
get filled
so
you're going to be able to compress this
to a point but at some point medicare is
put pushing back on you
with this every six month visit
to all of your attending physicians
so
but good for you i mean i'm i'm loving
it but thank you
thank you yeah uh this this was actually
a very good presentation and i'm sorry
that our uh
fiscal meeting ran so long because uh i
do feel that uh
there probably isn't a very good
understanding
of
what goes into
that
glob figure
that everybody complains about and says
well
d.a.s sets it
and it's all their fault you know
um
but it's not all their fault it's
it's all of this and uh
so i uh i thank you very much and um we
always like the chance that i mean i
understand that so much of what so much
of what we do and and we you know some
of the the
back office and the details and the all
the boring stuff as i once said
is something that people
um don't understand and i think anytime
we have a chance to explain it to people
we're always happy to do so and i will
note for the record that senator
d'alessandro who couldn't be here must
not have watched it on film because he
called me 10 minutes ago and he
apparently didn't notice that i was
testifying before you and so couldn't
well uh michael maybe we can uh
when
when the budget
stuff starts as
part of you know getting ready for
what we're going to be doing in the
budget maybe you can add this briefing
to
that long list of stuff that we look at
to give at least house finance a
a better understanding of
of these costs
okay just
oh yes
i just want to
thank
both of you and and the people on your
staff i um
i can't tell you how how many times i've
called the retiree help because i had
questions when i retired and you know
and uh there was always
you know there was always somebody that
answered or if they didn't answer there
was a message that said we'll call you
back within 24 hours and they always did
they always had the answers they were
very very helpful and so uh kudos to to
all of the people on your staff that's
why i always laugh when charlie says
it's all joyce it's not me there's a
bunch of people back in risk of benefits
they they
they do a really a really outstanding
job always had the answers and it was it
was always right so thank you very much
you're welcome thank you
oh one more question yes is service link
part of das or is that a different
agency hhs hhs thank you
yeah maybe we should move it from hhs to
i think we're good yeah okay you think
you think you have enough uh things on
your uh
on the table huh
okay well thank you all very much and
thank you to those who stayed and uh
you